I think we're live, right?
Hey guys, give you a sec.
I'd get to tweet this out.
Where are we?
Minus one.
What the fuck?
Am I level mine?
Mine said zero earlier.
Your level minus one with zero, zero, zero, zero, zero.
Wait, I don't know.
Okay, guys, we're live, by the way.
We're...
Okay, guys, ready?
I mean technically everybody can see us it's okay let's jump
right and jump into the camera guys jump into the camera
what are we what are we guys we are the sloppy sisters wait
it's just me a bit yay
Yes!
Which makes you guys look really small.
I feel like I'm going hanging out with my three daughters.
This is weird.
Wait, guys.
Let me zoom up to us.
Here.
Like taller than you right now because it's all messed up.
There we are.
Yeah, sorry guys.
We had a lot.
We were being really sloppy.
We were being very...
We had a lot of technical difficulties.
We lost a lot of technical difficulties.
mint yeah no it was pretty it was pretty hard so we lost
mint at one point okay we have mint was missing the entire
time no no you were missing we had to come to you we had to
find you we had to perform a seance yeah we were like we're
is we try to invite her and then she sent me a fucking poke
and it just sent me boo emojis like yeah yeah yeah literally
watch that yeah send it to me and i'll show you what it does
yeah i want to see it literally like like ghost emojis
started popping out and everything is i was i was also also
lime was like yeah lime is going through a lot of technical
difficulties right now yeah see this is what happens do you
see it oh you don't okay wait I'll show you what you you
would get oh I see it yeah you see it like there's like
ghosty bokeh starts popping I was like yeah so because make
you do anything okay but like I literally have to accept it
first I have to consent consent to it yeah I have to accept
it so yeah so it was just snuffy and I oh we're poking each
other so it's snuffy and I we were in we were like chilling
at first just waiting for everybody and then um mint had
like a lot of technical issues and so did limo so we're
trying to help limo with hers so okay there's a gingerbread
flying out of my body yours is gingerbread yeah yours is
gingerbread you know send them a poke on fucking facebook
how do you do the sweaty emoji that's what i'm trying to do
it only lets me boop so far oh here wait i can't accept it
wait what oh my god wait it actually i can't consent to it
it actually just gives it to me all right i'm sitting down
we've been we've been like trying to find mint for so long
i'm sitting down and then we lost and then min and i we're
already tired yeah min and i lost limo and snuffy because
for some reason they were forbidden to enter her world like
her was like locked out or some shit only like i could enter
it for some fucking reason if my tracking's all fucked up
what's it gonna look like if i try and sit oh wait sit down
do it wait i'll grab the camera over let me grab my camera
to see it i just i just sat on the tracker my ass oh my god
are you okay no hold on i just kind of fade into the grass
goodbye goodbye later but You guys like our like lying so
prettily.
Fuck you man.
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys like our new our new models?
Wait, where are you?
If I I could change if I change the camera angle just a
little bit You Okay, well Doki is live so Yeah Yeah, she's
just start Mm-hmm
Yeah, I hope you guys guys everyone likes our the new
models.
It's my it's my Christmas gift to the sloppy sisters Yeah
I'm enjoying everyone looks so cute Everyone looks so cute
We're all very immersed.
Slimes is just in ferret mode.
Yeah I don't know why I'm so low on the ground Yeah, show it
Look at that.
She's like, where is she?
Look, there she is right here.
Hi.
And...
Hey, oh my God, actually, you're leaning down on me like
that.
Hey, what's up?
There we go, there we go.
Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
My audio was totally messed up.
Super Jane.
Uh, I still don't know which way I'm facing.
Hold on, I'm going to kick out and see what I can.
Can no one hear anything like that?
Oh, my God.
Was it just me talking?
entire time no no did i mess up did i miss no no they should
be able to hear it no no they can hear they can hear i've
got i got one guy just straight literally literally one guy
said i can't hear and then i was like what they were like oh
i do that to myself all the time they were like snuffy your
microphone is sit to get the middle of your room oh they're
so okay i could i can fix the audio of every i can raise
them up i am using my desktop because i can't be like
getting a mic i raised them up a little bit yeah chat how is
everybody's audio yeah yeah how is everyone's audio guys we
still have like a couple of hours before i get my new year's
countdown i know i was yeah i had mine i'm still in the I'm
still in 2025.
They're all like, you will join us, Doki.
I feel like I'm shrinking even further into the fucking
grass.
It's so peaceful down here.
Yeah.
I'm my full body track.
I can use your, I would use your head as like a little,
wait, I can, wait, this is going to be immersive.
Watch this.
I can use your, I would use your head.
Wait, okay.
I can hear myself.
I don't, I don't know if I can get into this, this
particular, look at this.
Christ.
Wait, get a little closer so I can use your head as a little
stool.
This is mean.
Your feeling is so fucked up on this model dokey.
That foot was like in my mouth.
And I was like, the first time I was in the chat, that's
kind of weird, girl.
Okay.
I mean, I guess if you really want to.
Yeah.
Good job.
Am I listening?
I don't know if I'm...
Get away!
I didn't realize.
Oh my god.
I just realized I had my own stream pulled up.
That's why I was listening to.
I was like, why do I hear myself?
Oh my god.
Wait, does that mean like other?
Wait, were you guys hearing?
Were you guys hearing double audio too?
Were you guys hearing delayed?
Chat, were you guys hearing delayed audio?
sizing is so messed up that i don't think doki realized how
suggestive what she just did to me was no i know i realized
okay okay it was terrible i felt a little bit violated she
was like look this is gonna be immersive and she put her
foot in my mouth i just saw your face in her crotch i didn't
realize um get your minds out of okay i'm standing up get
your mind out of the gutter because i didn't notice any of
that okay i did not notice any of that nope i think i think
your chat did no no no i did not this is why i'm still in
2025 and you guys are in the future oh yeah we should go to
looking at you snuffy we should go to snuffy's world am i am
i fixed yet i'm not wait wait did we oh yeah by the way
limo's not okay right now
is it okay when we were saying like everything is sloppy
everything is sloppy really quick before we go to a new yeah
check your uploads you see if you do you see it yeah do i
yeah yeah because right now her mouth doesn't move right now
she's literally talking to her my mouth doesn't move
everything's disconnected horribly oh look i do she's
talking to us telepathically
Your mouth is moving!
You did it!
Oh my god, wait, we should...
Look, you're moving now!
You did it!
I did it!
Yeah!
You're a real ferret now!
Oh yeah, we have we have like stuff battle, we have toggles
and everything, I forgot to show it.
I don't know we have stuff my toggles.
Okay, well I can't see stuffy.
That's your job.
I can't teach Watch this Yeah That's what we were all saying
earlier
Also sound guy I fixed boosted everyone up volume wise.
Let me know if it's that's better Like, wait, you're doing
me now!
Snuffy!
Snuffy, where are you?
I need help!
Oh, wait!
Yes!
When people get too close to me, they disappear!
How do I...
Oh, oh!
She knows what to do!
People don't disappear for me.
Okay, but I'll show people...
So, I'm gonna tell you to do...
I'm gonna tell you how to turn off your VR chat firewall.
Yeah, we're doing...
We're gonna do tech...
My beautiful bars!
This is like a technical...
Like, a...
Like, tech help right now.
Really?
Oh, really?
Like, I can only not get close to mint.
You're fine.
It's because we're friends.
You're not friends with mint?
That's messed up.
Okay.
Oh, and then just click on none.
Not recommended, but at least in the private group.
It's okay.
See if that helps.
Whoa.
No, you still disappear when I get close.
No, mint still disappears.
There might be like no Snuffy's fine.
Snuffy's fine and Doki's fine, but mint disappears.
It's probably just shouldn't have you added as a friend.
Yeah, it's friends only.
That's what I said.
Okay, I did my fashion show.
Did you guys get my friend request?
I sent you one ages ago.
Yeah, I think you might be broken.
For some reason.
Yeah, you're not sending them and you're not receiving them.
Why are you like this?
I don't know.
I sent you one.
Let me just find where the, like, the setting is for that
anyway maybe we can just say like you oh uh i think what it
is okay so similarly to what i said if you double click on
the gear instead of shield level go to comfort and safety
and then unclick personal space make sure that's unchecked
so that yeah okay yeah i no longer value my personal space
around this so that's cool yay we did it everyone yay snuffy
how do i stop crying by accident you're gonna have to
practice just holding your gestures so if you don't like
your gestures auto moving uh if you hold b and pull up your
toolbar menu you can just you can just like disable gestures
i think somehow this is tech help otherwise they're
triggered to where your fingers are so like if you do finger
guns or if you do like pointer fingers or all your hands out
or something yeah so you guys wait stop you show your
expressions that you have show them to the camera look hello
everybody i got i I got a pair of these I don't know what
I'm doing Sorry, Mim's ass was in Oh,
I have this one too.
I really like this.
Oh, yeah, this was cute.
Yeah, yeah, everyone picked their own expressions We got
like seven free expressions.
Well, it wasn't free.
It was they were all very expensive How do I tell them it's
taking two hours to figure out how to do it?
Guys, maybe an hour wasn't enough, guys.
We were all here for like...
The last time I was in VR chat was when I was with you.
That was like 10 or 16 years ago.
Guys, that's why it's like, guys, okay, I was like, all
right, Snuffy and I, we should get...
We'll be there for an hour and early, since we're streaming.
But I think we should have all been here an hour early.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Yeah, just maybe, maybe.
Oh, yeah, Naima, show your expressions.
What do you have?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I show them if I just disable gestures so I stop
crying?
You're still okay.
Okay, bitch, what are your expressions while I'm who figures
out how to stop crying?
Hello.
Um...
I can be sad.
I can be...
Yeah.
This is how I'm feeling right now.
Oh, yeah, are you feeling okay?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Yeah, okay, that's good.
No.
Um...
okay so we gotta be crazy i'm so crazy wait it looks like
i'm doing six seven people are gonna it was inevitable i
can't do any of these on purpose because my hands are so
small that they're not be in the right places on the
controller it thinks i have a hand raise when i don't what
is this expression oh that's your you're angry oh that's
your angry oh my god
no that's not good that's not good what happens ah you're
like unhinging your jaw like a snake yeah yeah it's like a
snake where you're unhinging your jaw and then this oh yeah
and that's all i got raise the roof very nice raise the roof
i'm leaving my own because i can't trigger them on purpose
have you figured out how to stop crying why am i so big i
just heard floating up right now.
You're not on the ground.
You're literally floating.
Yeah, you're literally a ghost right now.
Wait, Lama, come here.
Show us your expressions.
I keep losing track of my chat on stream so I can't see it.
So if you guys ever have problems, I'm gonna request to
don't know.
If there's ever tech issues, please donate to me.
Please donate so I can see you're talking.
Please.
a wire piece ear of somebody fucking donating to me i i
genuinely don't know how to trigger these on purpose i
either cry or i'm not crying it's okay that's all we need to
know yeah it's okay it's okay wait okay sorry i should my
hands should be here it's okay it's okay and you can
probably have a version that you can just toggle the
expressions on that would be really nice thank you the
snuffy world now oh okay yeah yeah the world that you really
wanted us to go because it had fireworks whoops whoa whoa
what was that whoa whoa who was that was that you a fire
truck yeah what the fuck was going on there huh oh my yeah
is mint like is mint okay herself to the fish oh no wait
mint oh oh oh okay that's like don't take the jump don't do
it don't jump oh that was yeah for those who didn't see mint
was literally like standing at the end of the pier and she
was just looking down and be like do i take i was ready
I don't know why I'm floating.
I don't know.
Oh, are you floating?
Yeah, I was trying to fix it.
I'm going to give you the same thing.
You're floating more than you used to be.
If you go to the settings, just the regular settings, scroll
down until you get to tracking and IK.
Adjust the player height, the user real height, or the
avatar measurement settings, and just kind of play around
with that.
See if that helps you at all.
Oh, okay.
Wait, where is that?
This is like...
Okay.
Q&A.
It's near the bottom of the VR chat Q&A if you have tech
issues right now.
Oh, God.
I shit down.
You'll fix it?
Yay!
Yeah, you're fixed now.
Yeah.
You might want to recalibrate your full body.
Oh, I think you will be fixed.
You're just crouching.
It says I'm five foot nine.
Yeah, you're crouching right now, though.
And what?
Wait, you're going higher.
Wait, she's going higher.
She's my height.
It makes me tall.
Yeah, we know she's going higher now.
Look Your base stations might be calibrated strangely and
this just it might see might just think that's your like
your floor height Why is it?
Sometimes it gets confused about like the way your dream
height is it's finally giving you what you want Yeah, it's
like yeah, it's giving you a new year's resolution right now
Are you gonna go back to the pier?
Yeah, yeah, she goes to her world.
Her world has a mirror.
Oh no, she's going to...
Min, we're going to the fireworks world, Min!
Oh, it's too late.
She's gonna take the jump now.
Oh my gosh.
For those who are wondering...
There she is.
I like how the thing about her head just says Min.
She's gonna do it.
I like it says it for you, it says Min and not Min.
She's gonna do it, guys.
She's gonna do it.
Wait, she's fishing right now.
I saw her hold the fishing pole I saw wait what time is it
we're gonna miss the fucking countdown at this point okay
okay we won't miss it I was gonna say we're gonna miss the
fucking countdown oh no now there's two yeah they do that's
cute I just showed it down there just I zoomed in I'm like
snooping on them yeah we're like look at them we're like
little creeps just watching them like oh look at these two
girls fishing guys yeah it's just two girls one fish who's
gonna catch it yeah whoa chat I can see you again do you
still request donna walls I do because I feel like it's just
gonna What are you doing?
What are you doing?
Are you kissing?
Oh my god, kissing right before the waterfall.
I can see your camera slowly traveling over too.
I see your camera fucking flying now.
I'm fucking zooming in.
Oh my god, look at them.
Oh my god, they're so close.
Two green women.
What are you doing?
Is this what green women do all day?
They look like two skittles in one bag.
two green skittles oh they're so cute they look like NPC
characters in a game just like idling yeah yeah like we
gotta talk to them triple-a games only having like two NPCs
in the background god damn it we're just okay watching in
the sidelines
whoa you're gonna crash it we i want to join it wait let me
i'll put this here and then give me a sec guys i'll crash it
too real quick no i flagged on the camera i set it up and
everything it's okay i'll find i'll find my way back where
is it i accidentally messed up the camera that's okay we'll
get there guys there we go there you go i got the perfect
angle now all right and then i'll crash it it's my turn to
crash the priority after I figure out okay there you go
there you I'm going in oh my god I'm like in the water now
we how do I I died if you go jump in the water you die don't
guys don't jump in the water apparently if you jump in the
water you fucking die hey guys okay I found out I just I
don't remember it, but I'm hi, okay, so I found out if you
jump from the cliff to the water you fucking die
Yeah, I was like oh shit.
I literally drowned.
Yeah, yeah.
Why did you tell us you were you did it like three times?
Why didn't you tell us?
I was jumping on the rocks if she died.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
She know it all the time.
That's true.
why am i on my tippy toes all the time it's because you're
too short that could still be a tracking yeah but i will say
maybe a tracking issue it's not yeah i think i think so i
think it's just i think tracking i think like the wants to
adjust their model height uh go hold b go to quick actions
and then there's avatar height just so if you know portion
wise i know we're all rather short but it feels weird you
guys are taller than me i know i'm short too but you guys
usually callers and all of us wait where do you go that's
why that's why i'm not floating that's why my feet is
actually on the ground diagonal menu um and then if you're
in the main one go to expressions oh quick actions and then
bottom left avatar hate it won't what the fuck is 1.24
meters oh i do
Okay, I gotta grab the camera in here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I was not, okay, we gotta look at this.
Look, my God, look how tiny she is now.
Help me too.
Oh my God, this is kind of my dream right now.
This is amazing.
Giant women.
Might be the best thing ever.
I will be my leader.
Look, I see you.
Look.
I will.
Look at you.
Look, she's accurate size now.
You can like kick the minto.
Kick the minto.
Don't kick her with this boy.
Can you ask your chat how many meters?
Shit.
Any mathematicians in chat, you guys?
We need some meter conversions.
Yeah, yeah, we need some meter conversions real quick.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No, this isn't decent.
Hey, man, you got your cat.
You can't show that.
This is what I saw Happy New Year's
It's like Totoro Right there Mentoro Oh Mentoro Right there
Totoro Totoro Wait I want to put down the world now I forgot
Oh yeah yeah we got to do the fireworks world now okay i'm
gonna put it down it's like attack on it's also like attack
on titan google avatar height man quick chat wait yes i am
on you fix my dokey ask your chat how many meters four foot
11 is how many meters is four foot 11 chat i'm looking at
chat too yeah how many chat will help me yeah Okay, help us
please the portal.
We're doing 48.81 inches Three meters easily distract 100
100 and 1.49 1.49 1.49 1.49.
It's okay.
There's we put another one.
I don't think we're making it snuffy.
I put another one Okay, I'm actually smaller than I am in
real life.
These models are tiny so yeah yeah that's fine all right we
can go to the world now yeah yeah now we now you could drop
the word we were doing math yeah but we figured it out we
figured it out yeah let's go let's do the fireworks all
right let's go come come run through I'm running in are you
guys having fun everyone I hope all you guys are having fun
we're a little bit of a mess we're being a little bit sloppy
here we didn't i did not expect all the technical issues but
i hope you guys are all having fun just hanging out with us
and enjoying new year's eve what i'm in first oh no never
mind i'm here hello hey where's my camera behold the power
of an 8x3d cp where the fuck is my camera
They see me the FPS gamers are in here first.
Yeah, because we have the we got to get we got the gears
Yeah, we got the setup.
Oh my god.
How am I gonna find my water without knocking that shit
over?
Hey Where is my camera?
It's like one-sided.
Hold on.
Um, try refreshing your model again.
You should always cuz it's so zoomed in.
That's why Yeah, we figured it out Yippee I can use him is
it just the same one this time around?
Yeah, just like just click on it again, just like reload it.
Oh, there's my camera.
I don't know how to reload it.
Do I have to switch back and forth maybe because it says
it's alright.
Yeah, just switch maybe to Limon and switch back to this
one.
Okay, Limon time.
Wait, where did, oh, wait, I think Mint's still loading in.
Mint couldn't see the portal.
Can you invite her again?
Oh, okay, I can invite her.
Oh my god, I can't invite her.
I think you have to do friends.
I think you have to do Friends plus I can can't do invite
only.
Yeah, I Because what did friends plus it worked.
I have a bunch of people added on okay.
I don't trust any of them No, you should do it so you should
do like do not disturb or some shit.
Wait, can you join even if you're and do not disturb?
I think you can oh these people okay.
You don't get notifications.
Okay.
Yeah, that's even worse When you were in a private instance
earlier, I couldn't join for what it's worth.
Okay.
Um, all right.
I'll drop the portal all right close this window words i do
now have toggles thank you yes new instance only my friends
can join boom there we go probably just like sitting there
she's just sitting she just looked fishing right now she's
looking fishing we always lose mint we lose her in the
forest every time this is the third time we lost her guys
this is why we we lost her to forest three times before we
could start the stream like it's always the forest it's
always the forest she's literally in the void all right
hello again hello all right now oh hey oh wait that's okay
that's lamb i was like that that was mint because you were
green yeah i can okay wait no wrong flavor of green i got
her i sent it in but what are you doing so this could be
funny what's that oh you're doing the camera um where is my
camera oh there it is hi hi camera hello that's me hey
camera whoa what camera get closer camera whoa there you are
there's my camera now i can pick you up hey i can pick you
guys up dragons wait no we're doing the we're gonna do it
here right so should be here i feel like everyone enters the
the vr chat squat after a while it's like i don't want to
try and sit down with all these trackers on this that's why
that's why when i was like should i make you guys come here
like an hour before stream or like or like 30 minutes
because it's like it usually takes an hour i don't do
standing up true true i will vouch for that we're always
sitting on our that's why i got my herman miller chair in
the first place my leg muscles they're atrophied have you
guys ever use like a standing desk before i have a sand yeah
i have a sand desk i just never use it oh wait i admit an
invite but i don't know she i don't know if she received my
invite because i sent her an invite she might okay she's
just not getting this what we ask her to close vr chat and
reopen it i i i asked her that but i didn't i don't yeah i
don't know like i don't know if she like i don't know if she
like i don't know if she like did that or not like because i
asked her but she didn't like respond if she yeah she might
have just been like struggling with everything but yeah i
think just need to restarting in vr chat makes you look like
professor x or something oh yeah it's either that or we just
have to ask mint to do everything for us yeah i might need
her and stuff yeah i think i yeah i think we lost her to
avoid again i didn't trust myself not to like because i
joined her right no i joined her and i dropped the portal
all right i joined her i'll drop a portal and i invite you
to i think that is the plan that that worked last time mint
is the key yeah she is the key to the she is the key to
reuniting all of us okay i'm gonna go find her okay i'm
gonna wait oh i left i don't know what she's gonna say
i don't know it's okay she is the chosen man are you okay
man oh no she is she down there again
Wait, where is she?
Minto?
Mint!
I don't see her, guys.
Where is she?
Mint?
Oh my god.
Hello, Mint!
Wait, she's not here.
but I joined her I I joined her though where does she go
what is this world she's in why is she in so what is this
why is she in this world oh no oh no no wait guys oh oh my
god man why are you in this world man man where are you
why is she in this she was in this where does she go she's
still here she's still man man Mint!
There's just Song Goodman everywhere.
Where are you?
Mint!
Wait.
I can't find her.
She's in the Song Goodman world and I can't find her.
I can't even invite people to her.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can't.
I'm sending them all here.
We'll split up, gang.
We'll split up to find her.
The zombies trace.
Where do I go?
Oh!
I found you!
What the fuck?
We are trying to find you!
Why are you in the Salt Goodman universe?
Okay, here is the plan.
I dropped the portal.
We both joined And then I, we, like, okay, okay.
Oh my god, this is where I found her.
This is where I found her.
Yeah, this is, yeah, no, I had to, I was running through the
Saul Goodman matrix to try and find her.
I was literally yelling, BIT!
BIT!
I think my connection's really bad.
Oh my god, Snuffy, are you okay?
She's like, she's like trapped in the matrix.
No,
you should see what I was going through.
Literally was just shouting mid while running through the
soul groupings.
Like, we're all getting DMs.
Yeah.
Okay, I shall drop the portal now to get it.
What if I can't see it, though?
No, no, okay.
Let me go through first.
We should drop the portal, yeah.
Where are we going?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
It is called.
It's called.
Okay, yeah, you picked something.
You picked something there.
We'll just, we'll drop, we'll go wherever you're going.
You have not been taking, we're not doing the countdown in
the Saul Goodman room.
I refuse.
here in 2025 I refuse this I like we missed it because we
were we were in the song good imagine we missed a new year
down it
Oh shit, there it is.
We're in aircraft care.
Okay, fuck it.
Let's get.
God, damn, this is Mint's world right now.
I need to hydrate, guys.
Did they have Santa hats?
Oh my god, the fucking planes have Santa hats.
All right, here we go.
Time isn't linear in the Goodman world.
I swear to God it, buddy.
what oh my okay how to fly you can fly without an airplane
in most flight worlds this is useful are you happy we're
playing ace combat no wait no no no no no wait this is
actually bad this world is really bad i mean it's really
cool but like for people who aren't experienced in beer put
my cock
okay so uh so as the as the adult of the chaperone today i
will say that if you get in those if you get in those
airplanes you're gonna get instant motion sickness okay man
get in that airplane man i nominate you go in that airplane
right now
i believe so oh my god look this is i believe man go get in
the aircraft right now get in that
She's getting in the aircraft guys.
She's doing it.
Wait, why is there Steve right there?
She's getting in the aircraft though.
Where does she go?
Oh my gosh, she died and she died in trouble all the time.
into the club i think oh it exploded guys it exploded it
exploded what is she just okay man oh no oh no no there's
nothing left there's nothing there's no body or anything No,
no, no, no!
How did I kill?
She could have!
She could have said no!
Is she- Oh, she's back!
She's back!
So, I like how it exploded.
So what did we learn today, man?
What did we learn?
Plains are cool!
That's true, that's what we learned.
That's what I learned.
Oh my gosh!
You should drive it!
You didn't even get off the ground No, it's okay.
I have free will.
No, it's okay.
I heard what snuffy said.
No, I heard what snuffy said Okay, all right.
I'll try one time Okay Am I Stop gossiping
No!
Do you think I'm doing- Do you think I'm okay, guys?
Dude, oh.
Yeah, no, I don't think I was okay.
I don't think I was okay.
I think I was done, though.
I don't need to respawn.
I think- I think the reason why- Or water or sitting fixed
it.
I just do it with your eyes closed.
reason why we didn't I didn't get motion sickness is because
my plane didn't take off so like I think whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa I can't I can't put my tail bro why are you so
excited for it bro yeah bro why are you so excited I love Oh
Wait, she's going backwards.
Yeah, yeah, where did she go?
She just doesn't hear It's gonna explode.
It's gonna explode.
It's our fireworks.
Yeah, you know, there are fireworks.
Yeah.
Oh Whoa, yeah Carrier to celebrate yeah, whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa I'm not being the only one and I was all
right Do it do it don't be up.
Don't do it pussy do it Come on show us how it's done Show
us how it's done Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's someone my child's
like this is why our taxes are so high is so true It's
because anime girls are trying to fly planes There she goes
there she goes she's hearing um wait did she do it yeah did
she just release some flares where did she go where did she
died i think she went to the she went away i think limo
didn't know how to respond so she's stuck in the ocean you
got you go okay yeah let's go let's go let's go save her
let's go save her Lamo!
I see her!
Lamo!
Look around you!
Turn around!
Okay, okay, we realized you didn't know how to respond.
Yeah, thank you.
Okay, yeah, we're like, she's taking a while to come back up
from the ocean.
I was...
Yeah.
I was stuck in this smooth jazz dimension.
It's all here.
Yeah, we were like, wow, she's not coming back up, guys.
You can take sure you actually drown?
It's like elevator music land.
Yeah.
Oh, I leave.
I don't know.
Okay, you.
Yes, there is.
It's a fast, fast, fast music.
What's the?
No, it's not elevator music.
It's, um, fuck, there's a genre for it.
It's the fast, that's the racing music.
No, no, no.
You don't understand.
I'm getting smooth jazz.
You're getting smooth jazz?
Yeah, it's going to be...
I am not getting smooth jazz.
Eurobeat, I'm getting Eurobeat.
Eurobeat?
Yeah, I'm getting...
Like, before you guys arrived, I thought I was just in
purgatory because all I can hear is elevator smooth jazz.
I think you're actually died or some shit.
At least you hear something.
I'm in silence.
Yeah, okay, what you do, pull up your menu and then click
respawn.
Uh-huh.
That's all you do.
Yeah, like underwear says social in groups.
always yeah oh and we were rescuing limo she was like stuck
in the ocean they had to go they had to move the smooth jazz
dimension to rescue me yeah she didn't and i found something
even crazier like i don't know what happened but i was like
looking for you guys now this is gonna be like super insane
yeah i so doki you're probably the only person who has a
stream setting camera Yeah, if you pull out a camera or even
a stream camera maybe Look right there.
Oh, no hero Brian.
No, I saw him.
Yeah, I was like why the fuck is minecraft here?
Yeah, the hero Brian is here.
We look around I did I literally said like wait, there's a
minecraft here He was really what that means that sounds
just like a zoomerism Bro, he was like he was an OG
minecraft.
It's literally hero Brian
Oh Wait, I forgot.
Laibu, if you refresh your model again, you will be on your
tippy toes.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, we fixed her.
Yeah.
I'm flying myself.
I'm being fixed in real time.
This is wonderful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
No problem, my tippy toes.
I don't see him.
You don't see him?
You have to, he like, pops up randomly.
He pops up randomly.
Yeah, it's like, it's like different cameras have.
Yeah, I see him.
He's right here.
Oh.
He's right here for me.
Wait, no, no, no.
He is.
He's behind you.
He's literally behind Snuffy right now.
Wait, do you see him?
Yeah, he's right here.
See?
He's right here.
Yeah, if you turn around, he actually has, like, white eyes.
If you turn the stream camera.
Okay.
Maybe I should recap.
Oh, my God.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's literally a hero, bud.
He's here.
He's right behind us, isn't he?
I'm all turning around in my room wait oh yeah mint did you
restart your VR chat or like and at all or like because I
think we mean um because like you you can't join us I I've
been having trouble with VR chat for a while I don't know
yeah but did you restart it today or like before we got here
oh what do you mean before we got here oh like for today
like when when we're having the joining issue did try
restarting to fix it or no no look at what's look at stuffy
yeah there's stuffy wait where's the flying thing hold on
let me give me give me next to her wait i'm trying to find
her there she is oh
Mick what are you doing?
It's nothing.
I'm taking photos.
Yeah, she's taking photos.
Her legs are on backwards.
Do you see that?
Yeah, that's crazy.
She's concording right now.
Do you want to zoom in?
Alright.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, give me a sec.
I'll zoom in and then... This model has like an amazing slab
squat on it though.
Whoa!
Do I?
I like how people are like, call an ambulance and We're just
all here posing like lower your butt a little bit more
because you're all fucked up.
Oh Lordy Am I doing oh
She's alive She's alive
Yeah, we're trying to bring you back to life.
Yeah What the hell?
Yeah, what the hell?
I got a beard.
Thank you guys.
Yeah, but yeah, did you restart your game at all?
drinking but when you couldn't join us at first you don't
quite be our child no I can try again yeah yeah yeah try
again and then and then we'll try to invite you to a world I
think what it might be it's nothing because they're like the
trackers are a little bit on the slope okay oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right guys all right I'll try like our
you know okay I'll try and you okay guys we're really cute
guys we're gonna try and go to the world the countdown yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch this oh god I lost my mat again
all right I'll go I'll go try and go to the world nope not
there yes can you hear everybody a little bit I'm so sorry
all right Wait, I need it.
I need it.
Let me see if I can get this going.
Okay.
I'm going to touch my chat.
You're going to touch your chat?
Why is the musical Sinister right now?
Wait, why do you have Sinister music?
It's still Eurobeat for me.
It's the...
No, I'm getting...
Yeah, it's Eurobeat for me.
It's really Sinister.
Like, choosing menu screen type shit.
That's funny.
oh she's trying to restart yeah yeah yeah yeah all right oh
i'm talking in caps lock
okay all right i'm trying to set up the world now the world
i want us to go to yay what a very new year's eve what a
very great new year's year are you feeling I'm feeling very
festive right now.
As the last remaining 2025-er, I'm feeling incredibly
festive.
Oh, that's so cute, too.
You're, like, in the past.
I'm in the past, and you're all in the future.
It sucks, dear.
Don't come here.
Well, it's too late, and I have, like, 30 minutes left until
I have to be in there.
Like, you should have warned me earlier.
I have 30 to 40 minutes left until I have to join you guys.
Don't you think you were hoping you would be the ones to
save it.
they're like stop change the world
all right i'm gonna head to the world now integrated man all
right i'm gonna go hide my screen real quick it's very
important guys i just i like muted the euro beat right now
so they're gonna be like where's my euro beat they can't
hear you guys too they're gonna be like i can't hear you
guys it's not fair don't worry all will be revealed soon all
will be revealed change the world my final message where's
my euro beat it's too late i got rid of the euro beat what a
great new year's eve i'm having a great time though i'm
having a great time but um so everything is loading in
truly it does feel it does feel like the peak of sloppy
sisters right now the the sloppiest of sisters the sloppiest
stream for the sloppy sister but i'm having so much fun
all right the thing is there is something I have to do
though for this before alright I am going to I have to do
something I have to do something after that too
okay there we go
alright I have to go to another portal I have to go to a
portal to another portal it's a little complicated it's a
little complicated guys but it's the only way to work I
gotta go to portal to another portal and then after this
portal I need to invite people okay all right and then oh my
gosh I forgot another thing I have to do oh my it's so
complicated I swear it's all worth it guys it's all worth it
after that I also okay oh no stuffy might show everything
but before I get everything set up stuffy stuffy might
accidentally show everything before I get everything set up
oh that'll be awkward but it'll be fine it is what it is
there's the camera okay there it is there we go hello all
right don't worry everything is going fine everything is a
okay right now i swear no snuffy is not no no don't say that
guys okay wait
what a way to start what a way to start all right there you
go it is what it is
i forgot to tell snuffy to like also lime's here but you
can't hear i forgot to tell snuffy to to like um to not show
it does not show anything
They'll be awkward.
I sent an invite to Min.
I don't know if she got it, though.
That's a thing.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll give them a little hint with the music, though.
Whoa!
What is this?
Is she still on the plane?
Is she driving the plane right now?
I don't know if Min is getting the invite, though.
I didn't make it to that.
Anyone can join.
She still hasn't accepted my friend invite.
What a bitch.
I think she genuinely just having so much trouble.
I feel really bad.
Mint, no!
I'll send her an invite.
She booed me.
I'll boop her back.
Boop.
I sent her a boop.
I sent her like 20 invites.
eventually should there any more invites because it just
those requests whoa
wait is your is your is your is your camera showing oh no no
no no no yeah yeah yeah it is what it is okay just a little
red okay okay the issue is that I don't know if I don't know
if mince making it in I don't I know I don't know what
happened to your VR chat If she comes back and she still
can't get notifications and maybe just send her a wait I
have an idea okay I can't the thing is the thing is the only
issue is that I Can't throw a portal to this world.
That's the only issue But can you can you link it though?
I can't no no no okay I can link it, but then she has to
invite us because she invited us You joined off of her at
one point That is true, okay Wait, but then That is true
That is true Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay Okay, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, truly, uh We are truly the Sloppiest
Okay I'm zoomed in right now, because Doki's to show
something off okay do join join launch your own world your
own world and then we hop in and then we we join you
it's like she's like literally trapped in the matrix right
now we're trying to always trying to find men.
I don't know how her game was working like that.
She was in some sort of like developer game.
We're like literally our entire goal is just to try and
find.
She's in a breaking bad lobby.
She's fucking in breaking bad right now.
Literally looking at her fucking lobby.
Have you guys ever watched Code Leoko?
I'm getting Ileida vibes.
She's a the breaking bad obby it's not even a lobby it's the
obby and bring I need a back I don't know damn and Xana I
don't remember what it was you have to launch um with VR
chat closed no no no she can't because it's a private world
so she can't if it's a private world no no I had that issue
too yeah Yeah, yeah Yeah, it's a private world.
Yeah.
So she has to close it and then and then launch it through
the air Because I don't own this world I know it's crazy,
right?
I don't even own this world.
I Don't but this guy owns the world this guy owns that world
not me Yeah, yeah, this fucking guy No, Jim at all.
So it's like, is this just my hallucination?
Wait, wait, wait.
Can we get the camera on this guy?
Will we get a camera on this guy?
Wait, I'm gonna...
Yeah, yeah.
Get a camera on this guy.
And then I'll show this guy off and be like, I don't even
own this world.
This guy owns it.
I'm just going to keep my camera on me.
So just let me know whenever you're comfortable with showing
things.
Okay.
Someone toggle the camera and I'll show it so that it shows
this guy owning the world.
Yeah.
Wait, I got it.
Yeah, yeah, message the other guy.
Message the other guy.
Yeah, there you go.
All right, I'll show the camera.
You know who owns this world?
This fucking guy owns this world.
I don't even own it.
Get back on the fucking cliff, bro.
Get back on the cliff.
I own you.
You own this world and I own you.
You're not.
You're not getting holiday pay.
They're around, don't you guess?
Yeah, this fucking person is working on New Year's Day.
Dead says I'm the only one in 2025.
He's already in 2026 anyway.
That's a cameraman, by the way.
Bro, yeah, that's right.
I hired a Dragoon cameraman.
Oh,
shit.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Dragoon.
Okay, join me.
We're going to find Mint.
You join me.
You drop the portal for her.
Okay, and then I'm not going to...
Okay, that's the plan.
That's the plan.
Wait, oh, wait, wait.
Does the other dragon...
Is the other dragon NA?
Because I know you're not NA.
Okay, the other dragon drops...
Comes with me.
I'm going to invite the other dragon.
We dropped the portal for her.
then and then we just that's the best we can do that's we're
gonna go we're gonna find men again we're gonna find her
again guys it's it's okay it's okay we find
you okay okay I'm gonna close okay the camera's off right
now where is it okay All right, all right, we're gonna I'll
invite you two I'll invite you two and one of you guys are
gonna drop the portal men is offline
Dragoons you two get on the cliff dance for us while we
figure this out You two just Yeah, she literally said, okay,
I'm going to go back to Saul Goodman again.
Yeah, you two just dance for us while we figure this out.
All right, you two, yes, entertain my chat, entertain the
others while we figure this out.
Okay, I'm going to go find Mint again.
She's going to be in the Saul Goodman world again.
She's not back online yet.
I'm going to go back there.
Wow.
We're trapped in this place, in this hellscape.
Yeah, and then she, okay, the plan is that you, okay,
dragons, you guys have to drop portal where anyone can join,
basically.
We just hope to God that it's just us.
No, anyone can join, because that's the only way Mint can
see the portal.
No, it's true!
It's true!
She can't see any other portal!
I'm sorry!
It's like the other dragons, like, no, don't do it!
No, don't do it!
No, no, no, no, not the public one, but like friends, the
friends, not the public.
I'm not talking about the public.
I'm sorry.
I think he's dying, right?
I'm not talking about the public one.
I'm talking about the any friend can join.
Any friend, not the whole public world can join.
Any friend can join.
And he was really like, what are you thinking?
He's just like, they're freaking out.
I was like, you know what, I just invite the internet at
large.
I mean, okay, I think he's trying.
Oh, he like typed me.
Yeah.
okay um wait okay they're like mentioned okay the problem
the problem is that she's not receiving anything that's the
problem it's okay this will work this will work i see the
vision here i see the vision all right let's see if she's
she's back she's installed good All right, let's do this our
mission.
Let's do this All right, I'll see you guys there
This is Don't worry eventually we'll make it back in time.
We will make it back in time for the countdown We Oh my god.
Hello.
All right, here's the plan.
We come we we had a plan.
All right We have a plan.
We do?
Yes, we do.
Watch this.
Someone, they're going to drop a portal.
And you're going to go through it.
Okay.
You're going to see someone here.
That's going to drop a portal.
And you're the key to all of this working together.
Working at all.
I believe.
Hello.
All right.
He's going to drop the portal.
the portal drop the portal tell me when it drops okay i'm
waiting for the portal
i'm waiting for it we're all waiting for the portal right
now because we're like where are you guys waiting for it
don't worry about it whoa
oops i messed it up Here we go.
Am I?
I am.
Wait, is she dropping a portal?
Has she...
No, I don't see a portal.
Where's my portal at, girl?
Where's my portal at?
One day we'll have our portal.
Don't worry, we still have time.
We still have time.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, they had to restart.
Okay, wait.
Wait, they said, can you launch this?
I don't think you can, but like, because we've been going at
it for the last two hours.
But they said, they said, if you can launch this.
Okay, I'll try.
It doesn't work.
Okay, she heard that it doesn't work Plan I don't know plan
E What's plan E?
That's so weird.
I think I don't understand why you might need to make a new
account or something I think so actually because yeah, maybe
or wait get the get the VR chat wrap Do you still have the
VR chat rep added like AEV have she might be able to help
you Wait, I'm getting messed up messages.
All right.
No work.
Oh, he got DC.
It's not the same link.
Uh, wait, no.
It's a lobby.
I just made via the website.
Wait, give me a new link.
I need a new link then.
You're like, oh, it's not the same.
The links don't work for me though.
Yeah, she said the links don't work for her.
They never launch for me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Guys, I am not doing my new year countdown.
That's the final sloppy sister that has yet to be in 2026 I
refuse to do my new year countdown in the Saul Goodman room.
I
Refuse wait I refuse Okay, we got invited we got invited the
other Fucking it's like where you it's like the people who
are going insane they like go to this room I will fucking go
crazy being in this room other place okay here we go she's
coming in the other goon is coming in i can't blow my nose
oh no you're gonna hear me blow my nose wait actually i can
you can mute you yeah i know i'm trying to figure out there
it is i can hear that i mean i haven't did yet you're not
streaming okay they're dropping a portal What are you doing
with your arm?
Alright, I'll let you know when the portal's up.
Portal's up, can you see it?
Yeah, we can do it!
Go, go, go, you go in first!
You go in!
Oh my god, she went in.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta do this fast.
Okay, now you guys can't do it, thank god.
Okay.
I have to do that fast.
So we can set everything up again.
Wait, I need, I had to set everything.
We did it.
Oh, my God, we did it.
Okay, I'm going to go set.
Okay, all right, let me, I'll invite everyone.
Wait.
Guys, me, SOS.
I can't invite them, guys.
What room, what, what lobby did you do?
Wait, I have an idea.
Guys, I have an idea.
I shall drop another portal for her to go.
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Thank you.
Wait.
I didn't realize I was me.
Wait, okay.
I will drop another portal.
You gotta go to this other portal.
Yeah, it's because I can't invite stuff.
Yeah, I'm dropping another portal.
Okay, this is gonna, we're doing this.
This is very convoluted, but we're doing this.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Do you see this portal?
Okay.
All right, go in go in go go gas gas gas It's love time.
We still have time.
We still have 20 minutes left till the countdown
It's like a true this is a fucking but we got a fucking side
quest look through another side quest
You guys can't see it because I can't show it to you guys
yet.
I have to send everything up Okay, we're here.
All right, now.
Now I can, I should be able to invite them.
Okay, I can.
When did VR chat get so complicated now?
I remember when, like, I send invites and people show, like,
it goes in naturally.
Okay, there we go.
All right, all right, I got put.
All right, you stay here, Mint.
You stay here and welcome the girls.
All right.
I was thinking, wow, right.
It's like, I feel like I'm on ground.
day right now okay there you go all right don't worry all
right this is it this is the final world we figured it out
guys try who is we figured it out BAM there we go there we
go all right oh my god look i found her i found it i found
men okay all right i'm gonna show the camera now all right
i'm gonna show the camera are you guys ready okay it's too
late it's okay they don't see you guys first all right they
don't see you guys first it's okay oh wait no never mind
they might they might actually see you guys first they might
i need you guys to do the the first angle Three, two, one,
welcome to Dokiland!
Welcome!
Yay!
We successfully brought mint to Dokiland!
It really is.
It's fine.
We lay on the floor and talked about Avatar.
It was great.
Oh my gosh, wait, I'm gonna watch Avatar because I don't
know about it.
Ang's family.
Oh, wait, which avatar are you talking about?
Oh, you're talking about the last airbender.
She's talking about the James Cameron avatar.
But welcome, welcome, welcome to Dokilan, the dragon's
number one vacation spot.
It's like my own amusement park, but but it's it's better.
It's better than Disneyland.
basically um well we okay so technically um that's still
under construction
technically that's still yeah yeah yeah i didn't get the
licensing yet but yes thank you to sloppy sisters for coming
to my amusement park yay it's like a you know okay that's
what we're trying to figure out mint do you know what it's
called like those wild west recreations where like People go
to like a wild west town and they like encounter like you
know Yeah, yeah, I would know because I'm American.
Yeah, but she told me yeah, cuz like obviously I don't know
we're like we're so cold We don't have the Yeah, yeah, yeah,
but is that what is called?
It's like world.
Yeah, it's like West world.
It is like West world.
Yeah, yeah, so it's like Resonance fair.
Yeah, but that's like the opposite of a resonance fair
Yeah, and you can like walk around on the battlements and
stuff and have a feast and then they do jousting and they
fire the trebuchet and you get
Yeah, it's a big restaurant.
Oh All right, let me show you guys very cool the wonderful
Let me show you guys the wonderful world of Doki Lan.
Oh my god.
What is going on with the camera?
Let me show you guys the wonderful world of Dokilan.
Come with me, everyone.
Come with me.
As you guys can see, there are lovely merchants to our left
and to our right.
You can't go inside yet.
That was you.
There's litter on the ground.
This place has not been cleaned.
No, it's called immersion.
It's immersion right now.
Of course, there's litter on the floor.
There's like wanted posters too.
Yeah, it's called- I hate to alarm you, but that's actually
kind of bad.
Like, what?
Okay, alright, so how would you- What?
What which oh, yeah, if you click on them and start talking
to you Yeah
What do I not know I want to be a no How do I not know
there's an infinite system and then VR chat.
It's called the DPS I'll go to camera
The DPS system allows for uh, I just I just think I think
the P stands for penetration Oh DPS is like if you want your
avatar to be set up to get fucked twice wait wait a minute.
No, no, no, that shirt.
This is a bank sir Sir sir, this is a bank sir.
This is
Oh, yeah, so for those who don't know, oh wait cameraman.
Can you tell me about your DPS?
Okay, so No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
so if you click on Each of these NPCs, they start talking to
you.
So, yeah, it's out of service.
It's out of service right now.
So, it seems...
But the DPS?
After what Snuffy said, they don't want you to let him in.
They're not letting people in.
They're not...
30% interest?
This place is a fucking scam.
No, it's not.
This is not a scam.
This is the happiest place on earth.
It's the happiest place on earth.
Every dragoon loves this here.
Love this place here, right?
All right, dragon, come on.
Come over here.
I love how the jail is parallel to the person yeah so so
you're like crimes did snuffy commit oh she knows she
fucking knows ever since ever since she wrote about the DPS
they put the poster on you the public indecency I thought it
was gonna be the raccoon accusations dude it's just I mean
your posters everywhere though your posters are everywhere
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, I'll show you.
It's so cute.
Come here, come here, here, come here.
You guys are around here.
Come here.
Oh yeah, that's my statue.
They made it in the honor of me for being so awesome, I
guess.
Wow.
Yeah, I know, right?
No.
Oh my god, I thought you had, I thought your donkey bird,
like, models were, like, huge boobs.
I thought this was your head, and these were your huge
boobs.
She wishes.
Like, you know how like in like some places they have the
statues and they've been worn out because people...
Yeah, people kept touching them for good luck, you know?
They would touch it for good luck.
It's like, you know, rub the belly.
Yeah, touch it for good luck.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
So you guys can find your little mascot scattered around
here.
But not these guys, but there's actual, yeah, yeah.
Not these guys, but they're here to cheer for us too.
They're here to cheer for us.
Oh my god!
Yeah.
Yeah!
This is amazing, Toki!
There's one here too.
There's...
Oh, oh, I thought those were boobs again.
Yeah, and then there's the...
I love how he's got like a sweat band.
He's working it.
Yeah, he's working hard, man.
Oh, wait, wait.
Yeah, but I'll show you guys.
mint oh wait yeah there's there's your i boo's right they're
now called i boo's yeah your little i boo your little the
boo boo's but they're cheering for me yeah yeah they're
cheering for you they're all cheering for each other i like
i like the body pillow oh wait wait so here come here okay
you can play hopscotch here too cameraman cameraman i
thought so too they're like you can play hopscotch here
That's that sounds disastrous.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're doing it!
This is where we're gonna start hearing big loud thudding.
Oh yeah, I'm getting shit.
Wait.
I'll show you something.
Wait, okay, I'll show where it's snuffy.
Here, come here.
Come here, snuffy.
The farm.
Yeah, the farm.
There.
Are you growing more tomatoes?
Yeah, this is how we cultivate the tomatoes I'm trying to
hide from doki how many tomatoes can we just put on here you
can like smash it on the ground too oh oh the camera wait
get the dialogue cameraman get the dialogue for this oh you
have to it's very important I'm trying to hide from doki
Does that?
Oh, yeah, it generates faces.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
Where's my cameraman?
Kill it.
Sure.
You have a chance to pick a tomato with my face, huh?
How do I commit violence?
Oh, you have to, like, just chuck it.
I just chuck it.
This is where we're going to be doing our countdown right
there, though.
Right here.
Oh, oh, don't wait, Lai Mu.
There's another, there's one over here for you.
Come with me.
oh
my baby
oh my god she's sitting there with him that's so cute i love
that and then there's one more for for a minute guess where
yours at oh the graveyard don't cry don't cry yeah i can't
believe that me too is dead oh wait here to my cameraman
here Oh, I love this part, too, right here.
How much time we have left?
We have time.
Okay, five more minutes.
Okay, go up to that shrine.
You see him?
I think so, at least.
You have to go back and go back in.
You see him?
Go back and go back in.
Oh!
I got a coin!
Also, this is very important.
Cameraman, we have to look at what he says.
says if I
I told it's important oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I get the
camera for this yeah yeah yeah you like that sonny did you
like that yeah
not the rest of you were 20 25 it never came the V it never
came right there's the two rest in peace how much time do we
have left we still have five minutes wait I'll show you guys
one more area I'll show you guys one more quick area and
then we can look through everything more detailed alright
come over here come over here guys don't worry it's pretty
cool it's pretty neat and then after that we'll do a quick
five minutes right here oh yeah here's the drunk goon here
too he's he's a little deadbeat he's drunk he's a deadbeat
look it's your own wanted poster too over
here take it easy I'm taking it so I got the motion sickness
you know what crime you committed all right come here guys
you guys can come through here
come on you got this yeah you can go through watch this
welcome welcome to the saloon i also own this place too so
you want to buy any drinks or your food i'll be you have to
pay
oh it's tom and jerry it's my tom and jerry rug you guys
like it it's custom-made like god it's it's a custom-made
top of jerry rug you guys like it why is it why is it so
like well made i paid a lot of money for that i hate to tell
you how i feel about stairs dokey but this intrigues me damn
look at the decorations around here beer yeah you want my
doking beer here i got i got some beer right here some beer
oh my god yeah let me cheers let me cheers on your beer
cheers right here wait do you have another one yeah yeah i
do wait i think i do i think i have another one right here
wait i'll chuck this one at you catch oh my god wait it's
okay i have picked this one off the floor i have a whiskey
glass cheers oh my god your dick is hanging out okay it's
fine it's fine now No, no, it's not.
It's okay.
It's always fine.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Here we go.
Kink.
Oh, they actually collide.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, ma.
Now.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Don't spill it.
Oh, oh, they did it upstairs.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Come here, Snuffy.
Oh, don't get a drink challenge.
But.
Oh, no.
I'm not doing great at all, actually.
think i lost all right wait guys how do i play oh oh you
click this yeah yeah yeah they're already distracted wait
tell a tale dirt i broke my monitor with my head i knocked
my head against a monitor and then it never turned on again
it was a very expensive monitor
our first time together as the sloppy sisters right here oh
my goodness look it's our little it's our hats when we first
work together yes so cute that's their hats oh wait where
did we can pick them up yeah wait where did mint go guys did
mint crash oh there's mint mint she jumped come up here
It's our first sloppy sisters collab.
Look
I don't think we could put it on but it's like our I don't
think so.
It's like a memorabilia No, it's on the floor.
It's on the floor.
Can we do like a picture with us holding it up on our head?
Oh my god, we should yeah yeah together yeah the camera guys
right here you can do it yeah camera okay
yeah cute yeah oh we gotta go we gotta go the countdown's
almost soon guys we gotta make it come on come on come on
follow me that's the only 20-20-25er.
Follow me.
Are you guys okay?
We're almost there.
We're at the final stretch.
There's a lot of places I wasn't able to show you guys, but
we're almost done.
Okay.
Oh, my camera guy's having trouble trying to get through the
saloon doors.
Oh, no.
All right.
Let's wait.
This is where we're going to be doing a countdown.
No way.
don't look at my books no don't look at my books no don't
look at my look at my
my what is this no no no no no no no no no no stop stop you
guys can't oh it's a countdown you guys can't see it on my
stream yeah it's a count these are count okay watch yeah we
don't press any of the buttons yet but I will Look at okay,
look where I'm looking guys look over look over there watch
this guys I'm gonna perform a magic.
Yeah, look look at the light watch look at the light real
quick look at this Cameraman look at the light look at that
Let's yeah, this is like the Truman show we're all like
trapped in the sphere right now This is where I can control
I control the weather How old are you?
What's the Truman show?
Um, it doesn't matter about the age.
Um, it is Jim Carrey's one of Jim Carrey's best film.
No, no, no, no, no.
I do not need your vouch.
I do.
If anything, your vouch makes it worse for me.
I will.
The first fucking thing Snuffy ever said is I was like, she
was like, why do you sound American?
I was like, oh, he's listening to Americans on Ventrillo all
the time.
And she was like, oh, what's Ventrillo?
And then I felt like I turned to dust in real fucking time.
but yes we for the countdown we should all be here on a
little picnic that i packed for you guys cute oh my god yeah
i packed a little should we sit should we sit yeah okay i'll
sit down i'll sit down give me a sec i gotta figure out how
to do this gotta make sure i don't
i have my little briefcase here i kind of maybe forgot i was
wearing the knee trackers and just the floor yeah that's
yeah that's fancy right there okay you guys aren't tracking
your knees you might lose them oh my gosh thank you guys for
coming to to the dokey lot fighting yeah i am very very
excited to be here and thank you for making such a beautiful
lawn for us this is freaking awesome can i do you do i have
your good graces to come in here like yeah of course wait
should we announce the thingy that we were talking about in
the server yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so if you guys are
enjoying dokylan you guys some of you guys might remember
min and i did this before but uh when the world comes out in
public we will announce uh i guess it's an official because
we're like literally we're going to do it but we're going to
do an official meeting greet here in dokylan all four of us
all the sloppy sisters we're all gonna come you guys will
join the world and then we'll be jumping instance to
instance meeting as many fans as possible here in Dokilan we
haven't decided to date yet because like you know we're all
been all over the place but yeah yeah it'll be really fun
it's gonna be so fun meeting all you guys yeah welcome to
one minute one minute oh my god i wasn't paying attention
god there's uh 40 seconds left 40 seconds left all right
camera people remember to remember to show the show get the
angles everyone yes remember to get the angles wait wait
wait here i'll be here oh my god 30 seconds let's see here
it's gonna be the the fireworks are gonna be above us right
here
15 seconds, guys.
All right, I'll do the countdown.
Okay.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Happy New Year!
Where's the...
Wait, where's the five?
Stephanie!
Yeah!
I was like, guys, why is it?
It's okay, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it It
worked!
Yay!
Happy New Year!
I'm part of the future with the other Snoppies now!
Yes!
The timelines are restored!
They're restored now!
Happy New Year Snoppies!
Yes!
I'm so happy New Year!
Happy New Year!
I started this for working a 9 to 5 on my cute.
Happy New Year everyone!
Happy birthday to everyone!
Happy birthday to you!
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Feliz Navidad!
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum Bum bum.
Feliz Navidad Prospero annual y Felizidad!
Oh my god!
La monosa espanel!
Whoa!
So gifted!
It is...
Oh man, this is so cool!
I love the dokey fire!
weeks yeah huge shout out huge shout out to the project team
that's been working on this world for half a year now like
literally the last three days I gave them notes and they
added they like they made this picnic area in like three
days because I was like okay I need you guys know before
then it was like at the farm and there were built like ads
everywhere surrounding the fireworks I was Like, guys, we
gotta fix that.
I don't want to add...
I might not be great if there's, like, billboards.
Yeah, I was like, guys, we need a new area.
I don't want billboards around the fireworks, guys.
I was actually...
I was telling Snuffy the London Fireworks just last year had
an ad for Wicked in the middle of it.
Wait, really?
It's like...
Was it like...
Was it like a drone show with the Wicked?
It was...
It was a firework show, and then they have, like, an AR part
that they put on the broadcast, And the AR part had, like,
fucking wicked scenes in the middle of the London Eye.
I was like, okay.
That's funny.
That's so funny.
Okay, I just have to, I know we're all watching the
fireworks, but I have one question.
What is this?
No, okay, look, this is...
Sympathically.
Do you want to show it to the camera?
Go to the camera and show it to him.
He's right here.
He's right next to you.
Dude, what is this?
It's Goodreads.
Goodreads.
late night good reads what what's wrong with it's all right
sorry it's all right there's more good books down there too
it's what i read when i'm on a picnic you know good books
yeah we got romance in the three kings it's a history i'm
learning it i'm i'm trying to learn history right now i
thought it was a biology book actually it's it's It's like a
document.
Don't look!
What the hell?
Illicit Technic Books.
It's like, um...
Look, I'm support your local artists.
Support your...
Support small artists, guys.
Oh, that's my favorite tabloid.
Oh my god, who was it?
Who was that dragon?
Who was it?
Oh my god!
Go watch a cold play!
I like the butt.
Yeah, the butt is cute.
Hey guys.
Look, it's literally a biography.
This is how dragoons are made, guys.
Right here.
Right here, cameraman.
This is how dragoons are made.
The camera's walking away!
He's like, I know, he doesn't want to know.
This is how you guys were made, dragoons.
Right here.
I want to see oh yeah yeah yeah it's educational they always
ask where did they come from I'll show them this book this
is where they came from look cameraman this is where you
guys came from is it their baby book yeah it's a you guys
want to know that birds and the bees
oh yeah look there's a little dragon burger too here burger
yeah it's like Disney World yeah yeah that's why that's what
I'm saying it's better than Disney World this is literally
better Dokilan it's it's just it's even more expensive and
the foods are double its price it's even better Mickey Mouse
is like my idol he's a king of capitalism I want to be just
like him yeah and open my Yeah, ever since I went to
Disneyland and I bought a $10 churro, I want to be just like
him.
Yeah, it's like $7.
Oh my god, oh $7.
Alright, how much was a popcorn bucket mint in Disneyland?
Oh, I don't know.
At Disneyland?
Yeah.
I'm gonna guess.
$40.
For a fucking piece of plastic.
$40?
Yeah, I do be fair.
I don't know if that's really...
I feel like it'd be $50 to hold your popcorn.
Yeah, it's over 50 apparently.
It has to be over...
The price of the ticket, right?
No, tickets are like $100 now.
Right.
That's...
If it's...
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't know math.
Sorry.
Sorry, I went backwards.
It's a really difficult percentage.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
What's the percentage?
What is that?
That's like 30.
That's like one third, right?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, camera.
You guys didn't see this magazine.
Here.
Who was it?
Who was the dragon that went to the other other other
YouTubers concert?
Who was it?
I like the emojis again.
He was like, hey, cameraman, you didn't see this.
And the cameraman was like, yeah, that was intentional.
I like that I can do it.
throw this around and it flops yeah because it's like it's
made of paper it's made of paper yeah we could pillow fight
with them oh my god you're right
oh this is a girl's sleepover oh my god oh my god oh yeah i
threw that at you earlier this just looks wrong like i got a
whiskey in one hand i got my little You got your home by
your transformer, Yally.
Put some respect on the transformer's name.
Do you even know his name?
I don't know what your pairing is.
It's a rare pair.
No, no.
How dare you?
No, it's brainstorming and Chrome.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's not Chrome Dome.
That's someone else.
That's not even my rare pair.
That's not even mine.
I didn't know.
not know you were such a transformers fan oh I am I oh wait
did I I explain the mint I explain the mint about
transformer biology yeah do you ever retain anything about
my my knowledge I'm sorry do you use it with biology and by
all yeah oh no they're yes yes they're they're real people
okay they're real so like real people yes they're being
transformer art just in the Toyota Prius okay so so for
transfer so for the the the the bees and the cars basically
every transformer and that's in the bolts the nuts and the
bolts exactly nuts in the bolts every transformer has a has
a spike and a
I forgot what the other part was called is I just know about
the spike I just valve valve has a spike and a valve I was
like statement in the pistol yeah it's a spike is a spike
and a valve and then and because it's a valve because it can
lubricate itself with oil is it kind of like that joke in
the Transformers movie where they had bumblebee pee on a guy
like but it Was it like what?
I don't know.
Where are you?
What what transformers are you watching?
I don't know.
He like he like emptied like gas or something on a guy, but
it was like a piss joke.
I don't I don't I've never seen the movies.
It was you watched Transformers water sports?
Don't see him.
It's 8 a.m.
Don't do this to me.
This happens in Michael Bayes movie in the first one.
I know like yeah, he clicks on his like.
Thank you.
Like a soda can.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, Michael, Michael, Michael Bay had the Transformers
piss.
Did he enjoy it?
I think so.
Yeah, I mean, it's sort of like Miyazaki's feet logic where
it's just like...
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What do you mean by Miyazaki feet logic?
Well, don't you know, like the Dark Souls guy, Miyazaki,
he's like really in the feet, right?
Like dark soul Miyazaki is Wait Miyazaki is studio Ghibli
Miyazaki is studio Ghibli No, is it not?
No, Miyazaki is the guy with dark souls.
Yeah, Miyazaki is the guy that really likes poison swamps
and and dark souls Yeah, different Miyazaki there's more
than one or something goes wrong in a video game now I just
I just I just yell Miyazaki.
Oh is sick no not not my toto-toe roe not not him no no no
he's a sick and quick freak fetish men is a freak phantom
again and notice how his toes are out that's is that why
totoe roo doesn't wear shoes is that what that's why totoe
roo doesn't wear shoes because Miyazaki is sick and twisted
What the hell?
That's why the wolves in princess mode and okay, don't wear
clothes.
Oh, Stephanie, your skirt is all kinds of fucked up, girl.
I'm drinking my beer.
You need to restore your decency.
My goodness.
Me?
No, her.
Her skirt's so short.
Look at how short her skirt is.
That's not true.
Okay, put, oh yeah, we'll do that school rule.
Put your hands down.
Put your hands down and see how far, yeah, look at that.
Your skirt is slower than your pants.
It broke the rules.
It broke the dress cool.
Yeah.
If you put your arms down, dress code.
I think I just have really long legs, you guys.
I'm getting so many panty shots right now.
Man, she was lying down.
I had no choice but to panty shot her.
That's my defense.
What's wrong with that?
I'm getting panty first leave.
Yeah.
But your glasses.
I didn't even see you had those.
Yeah, freak pantomit.
she did yeah what oh i must have missed that uh give me a
yeah yeah happy fucking new year's happy new years everybody
happy new year's happy new year's everybody new yorker voice
yeah hey i'm walking here hey i tell you your car is the one
accent i really struggle with we try Try it.
Try it.
What do you want me to say?
Eh, I'm walking here.
Eh.
I'm walking here.
It's pretty good.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
When you do it, it's a lot less threatening.
You're like...
Eh.
This is the only New Yorker we know.
Where is my pizza?
Antonio, where's my pizza?
So it's like the funds.
Hold on, I gotta recalibrate.
Oh, shit, she's T-posing.
There she goes.
I just realized I'm like so far away from my microphone
right now.
I just look up there somewhere.
It's fine.
I think you're just using the VR chat mic or something
because you sound really good.
I'm using my VR.
Am I?
I'm using my VR chat.
No, I only have one microphone.
It's up there.
Yeah, there's a built-in mic though.
No, there's a built-in mic on your...
Built into what?
Your headset.
If you go to your settings, it should tell you what you're
using.
Poor little baby.
No, no, no, I have the big screen beyond.
It doesn't have a mic.
Oh, what?
But it sounds so good.
Like, you sound like you're so close to the mic.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna go touch- I'm gonna go smack my microphone and you
let me know if it makes a thump.
Oh, fuck, I can't get up.
I had someone go break in.
I can get up.
Wait, hold on.
Where's my mat?
Which way is my desk?
I'm a stuck.
Look, okay, I found my desk.
I found my desk.
Where the fuck is my microphone?
Oh, God.
Oh, you're seeing.
Okay, I'm hitting my mic.
No!
No, it's not.
It's your headset.
It's literally your headset.
Is there a headset mic?
Yes, it is.
I'm going looking.
It must have hijacked my audio settings then because I
didn't pick it.
Yeah, but it sounds good though.
It does sound good.
It does sound good?
It'll just...
Yeah, it sounds great, actually.
If I hit my headset, can you...
Is that it doing it?
Where's the microphone?
I don't think so.
It's usually like for the CBR, it's kind of like right here,
like under the eyes or by the ears.
She's so smart.
I really know that because I touch it so much on stream that
chat is always freaking out and being like, ah, you hit the
mic.
She's like the professor.
We're having a TED talk.
I love my monitor.
Professor Snuffy right there.
So you don't know that tapping.
I just realized your hat your hat looks like those like
professor hats like the graduation cap slash things yeah
yeah she's really a scholar right now teaching us VR right
now he's so small
It's just small.
We're all small.
We're all the same height.
Wait, can we- how did you go- how did Mint go super tiny
earlier?
How did you do that?
I learned I graduated from her school.
Oh my god, she learned her lesson.
I slept in her class down the B button Yeah, go to uh go to
expressions and then go to quick actions Then there will be
avatar height and you can get as big or as tiny as you want
to be like this Now she can read so immersed.
Wait, that's how do I why is it my head?
Why is it just my head?
You're like a kaiju for real.
Okay, it's oh my god.
It's like Marvel.
I'm so cute.
Wait, look how tiny Minus look cameraman go look how tiny
she is
Where's my foot?
Nuffie!
This movie are just the cutest.
I'm going to scream.
I need this.
We need a little bit of action for you.
Wait, why is my- why do I have another body?
One of my little toesies.
Look, I have another- do I see the double body too?
I promise I won't grip you hard.
I like how I can be tiny and offer you the gigantic burger.
Your eyes are so pretty when you're so small.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, Limu.
Oh, little Limu.
Hi.
This feels like an episode in Adventure Time where he just
like has little people and like picks them up and makes like
weird social experiments.
Oh, honey, I shrunk the kids.
Oh yeah.
Oh gee.
Oh my gosh.
I've shrunk the sloppies.
Whoa.
This is the perfect angle.
Yeah, we gotta do the Totoro dance where they are crazy.
Yeah, like...
Minto, Minto, Minto.
Guys, ever since I sat down, I couldn't get back up.
Yeah, I don't want to get...
Wait, I'm not...
No, I'm standing again.
Oh, great.
Oh, my goodness.
That's so cute.
That is cute.
I like that feature.
That's fun.
Yeah.
That is fun.
I used a lot with my Lamon avatar because he was like, he
came through really big, which was really weird.
He's not supposed to be that big.
He was like a master.
Wait, wait.
Which, dude, your Lamon avatar would look like Totoro?
Wait, you should try that out.
Yeah, he does.
Yeah, I would.
He's round.
He's just as round.
You gotta be big with him.
Oops.
But man, people in chat are like yelling at camera for not
going under your...
You're scared when you were big.
When you were big, they're like, cameraman, you had one job.
Okay, be nice.
What are you wanting?
What are you doing?
Holy shit.
Whoa!
La-mo-mo, la-mo, la-mo.
That's so cute.
La-mo.
Mama, mama, la-mo.
How do we look when you're so big like that?
You are very, very tiny.
So big.
It's like we're like, we're like, They're like Pudo Land
right now.
I feel like I'm gonna be engulfed in like fluff, just like a
chinchilla fluff.
Oh, that's cute.
I'm gonna try and get up.
Oh my gosh, good luck.
The VR tracks, it took everybody.
Oh, it was so nice though.
It was so nice.
Oh my god, you're so tiny now.
Look at you.
You're like a Pokemon.
This is like a grass starter.
Yeah.
yeah look at her go she's dancing oh she's dancing no you're
gonna turn into furry bait his mom's gonna get sexy okay
whoa look at her whoa shake that shake that tail girls shake
it that's right show them what you wait I got an idea I got
an idea I don't like that oh shake that tail yeah yeah shake
that tail yeah
where are you i can't tell it's still loading can you not
tell she'll never know just see how vr chat stick man like
that's Shaking their stick butt You'll find out soon.
He's croaky.
That's me That's me I let it in oh my god, yes That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Take that too.
Take that too.
Yeah You gotta get what are your math?
Yeah Hey, where's yours?
Join the fun!
Oh, you can?
Where is she?
It's Frog Bird!
I've seen you on my cereal box before.
It's Frog Bird.
You're probably mistaking me for a really popular and really
well-known frog that everybody mistakes me for.
No, no.
Everybody thinks I'm at Kermit.
Yeah, Kerbo?
Can you sing over the rainbow?
Yeah, can you sing over the rainbow?
They will find it.
The rainbow connection.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
You should be like his understudy or some shit.
And me.
This is our mascots and the sugar snaps frog.
Yeah.
How I'm like so tall.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're like the You guys know boy's throb you guys know that
Ben Oh, I want to like go in between your legs.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you guys are missing out peak No, you guys are missing
out peak.
You're trying to get a boys 12 Almost yeah
There we go.
Oh my god, there you go that we can be we should start a
band We should we should start a band guys.
We should guys guys the sex appeal.
Whoa Yeah, you got the moves bro.
You got the moves Frogby I'll be the bad crow.
I'll be the bad bird.
I'm the bad bird Wait, what are you two?
What are you two then?
I'm I'm a hmm I'm a I'm a I'm a isn't there like an Elvis
song about dogs or something bad dog wait no there can only
be one bad there can be only be one you're the that's my
solo all right Lama what are you huh what are you gonna be
we got the hound dog we got the bad bird we got the sexy
frog what are you I'm like the one that just like plays
innocent and every oh your baby you know like baby spice
actually was secretly doing crimes you're like that saja boy
you know the saja boy who went google gaga
yeah he's the he's the baby he goes google gaga i feel like
i feel like a mom because like i watched the macy's day
thanksgiving parade in america they had to do it in new york
and they had like golden or what yeah i've never seen k-pop
demon hunter i feel like a mom where i'm like that is that
song that the kids are singing oh my god oh my god oh my god
i heard my kids singing that song like 20 times today i only
watched it for the first time like last week oh shit okay
this is
Yeah, we're going up
Chad should I watch kpop demon hunters?
Is it actually as good as everybody says?
It's I'm like scared.
Okay, I can't give an opinion because I might get cancelled
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Controversial.
I think it's all right.
I just I think it's all right
I did say that I would like to a disclaimer mint was the one
that said it was a kids movie I just said it was all right.
I said
I'm sorry this is Talking right now.
This is yeah, yeah Crokey here says it was all right, but
Crokey did not.
Yeah Frogbird said Frogbird said it was a kids movie Crokey
said it was all right I did not say anything else after
that.
I said it was it was cute.
Yeah, but you said it was for kids I did not say that Oh,
it's an actual kids movie.
I mean for real.
Oh, well, geez, you heard that guys.
Frogbert said that.
Frogbert is a regular movie critic.
I respect their opinions.
That's right.
Wait, Lamu, have you watched K-pop Demon Unders?
No.
Oh, so she can't give an opinion.
She just wants to watch Avatar.
Oh, yeah, you're obsessed with Avatar.
I already watched Avatar.
you heard me i had a good time i like that you know that
hang had to die for another avatar to be born we had this
conversation already wait i have something to show you okay
there's a there's an avatar fighting game where kora and ang
are fighting against each other and you said one must die
that's why they're fighting that's why they're like this
can't be happening this can't work Right now it's a paradox.
It's a paradox one must die That's why they're fighting.
It's in the afterlife.
Yeah.
It's in the afterlife because they're technically they're
both dead now Yeah, wait what?
Kora don't you remember in season two Kora teleported to the
to the demon realm of the souls and she met the first ever
avatar So technically that's true in their past lives.
They're able to reunite and fight each other.
That's true That is true.
I'm actually you know like mint.
Oh sorry frog brute thought that like Wait, was it you that
was saying like what if like They made another avatar like
like was it you that was saying how like Why did why did
Aang have to die when he could just like When he just can
just streamline the avatar process Where he dies in the
middle I think it's kind of lame that his kids didn't become
the avatar Yeah, yeah, yeah, so That's like a Nepo hire
Yeah, so she we were talking about like what you want like
Is that genetic?
I thought so Yeah, no, like, yeah, so Min's, sorry,
Frogbert's idea was, what if, like, you know, during the
middle of it, during Conception, he passes on the avatar.
So, like,
so then, so then you secure the line, you secure the avatar
line.
You keep it in the family.
He takes a pill of cyanide while having sex, just so his
kids get the guaranteed button today.
He bites the tube, bites the cyanide tube in the middle of
conception.
Do you think when he gets older, people get like really
freaky about it?
So they're like, dude, Eng is like 88.
We gotta get you.
We gotta get you knocked up.
That's what I saw.
I thought, what's her name?
Katara.
I thought she killed him because I was maybe like.
Someone in chat said, he's the avatar, not a fruit fly.
I swear to God the new season is gonna talk about this I can
see that I can see that people do avatars are twins
apparently spoiler sorry spoiler spoiler there's a new
avatar it's coming out yeah it's coming out and the cons
spoilers by the way the concept is that they're planning on
making the avatar twins so I don't fucking know how that's
gonna work your whole everything your whole explanation has
been I think they said that only one of the twins is the
avatar so there's probably gonna be the whole idea of like
oh my sister's the avatar but I'm just the inferior yeah how
dare she metal gear wait a second that's everything's always
metal gear everything is like that's just like metal gear is
that a metal gear reference is that yeah is that is that
metal gear reference guys is that frog bird are you in the
metal gear i know somebody who is but i don't know about
frog bird man that guy's in everything are you a poser frog
bird if you know medicare name If you know Metal Gear, name
5 Gears.
The bolts are nuts.
5 gears.
What's the nuts?
That's not a, excuse me, that is not a gear.
It is, it is, it is.
A bolt is not a gear.
Where the fuck does that come from?
See, I told you, Frogbert.
I'm trying to escape from this.
I don't want to become one.
Become what, Frogbert?
Whoa.
Opposer.
Hold on, not.
I'm trying to escape becoming a poser.
Help me.
Please, I don't want to be a poser.
Wait, wait, wait.
I just realized something.
I fucking love the rat.
It's such a good...
Wait, wait.
Wait, I didn't...
Wait, I wouldn't be...
I realized this, like, Lai-Mu hasn't said anything in a good
moment.
Oh, no, Lai-Mu, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Oh, Lai-Mu, thanks for being here.
Thank you for inviting me.
I love you guys.
I'm sorry I'm gonna hate you.
Thank you.
Come here, mental rat.
Come here.
Squeak, squeak, squeak.
Squeak, squeak.
Just the model polygon collision cuddle.
It's beautiful.
I'm touching you but my arms don't work.
Guys, thanks for all for coming.
to my new year thank you for inviting me thank you everyone
I told you please leave a five star reveal on Yelp please um
after you after you leave Doki Lahn I really appreciate it
broke my please please leave a five star reveal I'm Google
reveals on Yelp I really do need it you worked so hard today
yeah it's alright you worked so Yeah.
You stayed up and made sure that you were even here for us
too.
Yeah.
You drove a plane, Lymo.
It was so cool.
You drove a plane today.
Yeah.
We saw...
What's his name?
Your favorite guy in Breaking Bad.
We saw Saul Goodman, too.
We were in the Saul Goodman.
We got...
I thought I was gonna lose my fucking mind in that world.
We saw...
We were in the Saul Goodman world.
You're gonna go to sleep.
You're just gonna be back there in that world.
Yeah, you're gonna sleep in that world.
But I fucking sprinted for it, holy shit.
Sit down too!
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my god, we're so cute, we're in a cuddle pile.
Yeah.
We are.
I like how being a VR trucker makes you feel like an old
person, though.
You just very slowly, carefully get down onto the floor.
It's like, oh, better not break my hip.
I think getting up is so worse though.
I'm so comfy on my hard ass floor.
Oh, hey, wait the cameraman literally took a picture of us
with You guys heard the click?
I was like click click
Click click Yes,
you hear that?
A night to remember This is, he's like the paid guy who
takes our photo at Doki Lawn Oh yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
Photo?
You're like, um, if you want to grab your photo, go to the
front of the...
Not the money!
He goes to the front of the...
You gotta go to the front of the counter to pay for your
photo, guys.
Yeah.
Uh, we do four by eight, 12 by six, so...
Uh, would you like he has a keychain?
Or, uh, would you want like a form?
Email it to you.
Yeah, it'll be cheaper if you want an email.
thanks you guys for celebrating new years with me the
sloppiest way i've been looking forward to this forever i
was like holy moly i want it so thank you very much for
inviting me thank you for setting all this up these models
are also fantastic dovey who did the models oh yeah it's
wait give me a sec let me pull it up real quick i can pull
it up guys it's really right yeah yeah it's seven men i'm
sorry i'm brainwashed
i'm trying i'm trying to remember their full names right now
it's it's it's really from artemis calms i think you can put
it in the description of the stream yeah yeah it's it's like
in the it's in the you know the info board wait is it an
info board no it's not sorry the info board Yes, the
dragon's like, no, it's not there.
It's not there.
It's The thing is, if I to look at the credits, I have to
stand up, and I don't want to stand up right now.
I can, I can, I'm gonna scoot.
Do you see me scooting?
I'm scooting over.
Yes, I see you scooting.
Okay, I'm grabbing the credits real quick.
It's there.
I'm scrolling up.
appropriate okay it's you guys might remember the artists
were these models because men and I had this artist work on
our previous models before a long time ago and it is
Katasumi yes remember before this is the same this is
literally the same artist or it's literally the same artist
but she improved yeah he improved a lot the style changed a
lot yeah some familiar Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's Katah...
Sorry, I had to take my headset off.
It's Katah Sumi.
Did the artwork, the concept design of everything.
And I can see you playing with my hair.
Are you okay?
Is this your sim right now?
I'm really tired, too.
And then the ones who made our 3D models is Aruno Rudo Ryu
and Rika Marjaja.
I'm sorry for butchering your name.
I'm really sorry, but all the credits and stuff I will post
on on social media and This description and tomorrow that's
the question mark question mark I have a question mark
question mark question mark stream tomorrow It was just
talking about this project and everything Oh Yeah So I'll be
talking about the project behind the scenes of it This one I
will say for this one this was the most off hands I've had
for it I did like come in with like several the Easter eggs
and stuff this one was the most off-hands I had I delegated
mostly to the project leader wait you can actually flick
that yeah you can so a huge shout out to the project team
this one had to be the most expensive VR world I've ever
funded no you can actually flick around with that that's
cool it is a lot I feel like a phantom pain was it or not
pain but a phantom sounds like this I don't think so no no
it's not i was trying with your ears too oh what you can do
did you just do like my twin tail did someone grab my twin
tail yeah it's interactive my twin tail yeah there's physics
this is what girls do at sleepovers you are doing it yeah
yeah yeah oh i think it's friends only you're not her friend
yeah yeah i can play with everyone's hair though because i'm
friends with everyone like when you get requests again i
sent one but it won't be sent another one because it's still
waiting contact a a v av she's uh they're still the vr chat
employee so contact them and be like what's going on i'm
gonna like see if maybe i can accept people on the website
oh that's true yeah yeah but if it doesn't work just contact
them they they can help you fix it your account you might be
my host okay can you play with my hair then yeah i can the
little here see oh yeah you can yeah oh yeah stuffy had one
toggle that wasn't finished she was gonna have her own yowie
book or sorry not yow yuri book she was gonna have her own
I don't know if that's better.
Oh my god, I took your camera.
You took it.
You didn't get my permission.
You're like a fucking paparazzi and like a paparazzi here.
You're like, stop filming.
You and this is the way they get in there and start pulling
and punch the camera out of the way.
Stop her!
Quit filming me.
I'm making a public embarrassment of myself.
Sorry, Mr. Dragoon.
We all look so cute, guys.
I'm so happy.
We all look so cute.
Yeah.
Like, I literally, I do a lot of VR chat.
I mean, obviously, for being scholar, snuffy, but this world
is fantastic, Doki.
All the details and the interactive stuff is so well done.
We didn't even do any of the games, too.
We have games here.
We'll have to do that.
Especially when we do the meet and greet.
We can show people for something.
Yeah, we can challenge our fans, too, for some of the games.
Yeah.
That'll be fun.
Yeah, we have, like, several games scattered around the
world, too, for the interactive and stuff.
But there's a lot of fun things around.
Like, you fucking, like, boxing my hair right now.
Isn't it your little fidget toy?
You're like, Yeah, and you're like
I'm like a cat.
Yeah.
But yeah, all of these models we'll be able to use on stream
too, but we, it's not, it's not, right now it's not ready
for a stream yet, but it will be maybe like by the end of
this month, or yeah, this month.
It's January 1st now.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It'll be so much fun with these.
I'm gonna use mine all the time, honestly.
This is just, it's such a good model.
It's so cute.
You look so cute.
They're very so cute.
We all look really cute.
I'm really happy.
Uh-huh.
I got my fucking gun.
Oh, wait, me too.
Wait, yours can, yours actually shoots.
Do it.
Take the shot.
Yeah.
Yeah, we could do, like, the Wild West.
We can, like, turn around and walk 10 steps and fire.
I like how yours is, like, a traditional Wild West gun, and
then Snoopy's got a fucking gun.
with a laser sight this too is metal gear is this a metal
gear reference yeah this is my cqc don't worry don't say
that remember what i i actually found a metal gear reference
the other day like a legitimate what was it what was it i
was playing i was playing this game called my little puppy
don't play it by the way like emotionally devastating yeah
no i made my entire chat like have just a mental breakdown
but like there is this one section where you do stealth
there's this one section where you do stealth and they do
bring out the box they bring out the metal gear box and you
use it to get put so you know you could play it if you want
the metal gear reference but just prepare to be like
emotionally broken for it's okay the rest of the day i'll
tell you this the dog's already dead the dog is already dead
i knew it and i saw it on steam i was like a game about
Yeah, yeah, but it's a game.
Jesus, the dogs are already dead.
The dog in heaven having to stealth around.
It's a whole thing.
People are like, spoilers, Doki.
You literally see the trailer and the fucking dog has a
halo.
Like, we all...
Yeah, it's not a spoiler.
The premise is that he's already in heaven.
He's in heaven and he's waiting for his owner to join him.
Oh.
That's so sad.
She's playing it.
One day, he's like, I can smell my owner.
I'm going to go find him.
So he sets up on a...
journey through the afterlife oh but it has a metal gear
reference meant that's perfect i got i got i got completely
fucked up by it though because like i have red hair and i
have two pomeranians and then like at the very start of the
game they did like a reunion scene and this pomeranian was
like he was he suddenly stopped playing with his toy in the
afterlife and he sniffed and this little girl with red hair
walked through the fucking gates and they were reunited I
hate the tears.
I was like, oh, what the heck?
They clipped me up.
It's so it's targeting.
Only a sick person makes again like the...
I bet they made a lot of money off of your grief.
Yeah, and that's what's important.
No.
As long as you can monetize it.
Support Indies.
Monetizing my tears.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, there's been guys.
If you guys are...
Leg is broken.
I think I think all of my trackers are starting to give out
and it's like it's nine in the morning Yeah, everyone's like
everyone's down and we just start like breaking down.
Oh, no We're like fanatronics my leg is my leg is going can
you say it like keeps lagging out.
Yeah, I see it You look like you're like driving a manual
Alright, I'm getting up!
I'm getting up!
Oh no, she's doing it!
They're going to bed.
She's doing it!
The VR rollovers.
Come on, Grandma.
I need that dusty trail.
Wanna stay down here.
Get up, Doki.
Come on, get up.
Get up.
I give you my out hands.
Come on, up you get.
Doki!
Ah!
There we go.
Alright, Snuffy, it's your turn.
Oh, come on, Snuffy up you get.
There you go.
Whoa, whoa.
Yeah, she's so good at this.
She did that.
There's some weird tracker shit going on right now.
I'm fine.
That was fun though, guys.
Thank you guys for coming.
Thank you.
You guys all sound so dead.
I only think they don't know why we woke up three hours.
I wanted to put my wheels down.
That's exciting.
Oh, my gosh.
Yes, your toes.
You're so normal now.
Oh, yeah.
love each other's don't know why but that's cool we are
everyone here is i'm so fucking tired but thank you so much
for an amazing night i had a wonderful time it was worth
ruining my sleep pattern for it's okay it's just for one day
lime it's just for one day and then you go back one day we
will be vr chat friends when it starts behaving
Oh, thank you.
All the hard stuff.
I think you should be patient with it all too.
Thank you for coming, Namo.
It was her that no, it was so early.
Where you slash lay.
You literally slash lay.
I haven't been asleep yet.
Wait, you haven't slept yet?
No.
No, I haven't slept yet.
Yeah, she hasn't slept yet.
No, I'm going to bed.
Thank you for coming, Namo.
Love you, Namo.
I love you guys.
Yes, yes.
Oh wait, wait, I'm trying to figure out where to go.
Here we go.
Group high, group high.
Yeah.
Sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy,
sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy.
Okay.
Good night, everybody.
I'll stay here for a little bit longer, but let's say
goodbye to everyone.
Goodbye, Happy New Year!
The Sloppy Sisters wish you a happy 2026!
Yeah!
Alright, bye.
Say goodbye to the rest of the Sloppy Sisters as they head
to bed.
I will see myself.
I will Sloppy.
I just hit my arm against something.
No, I know what it was.
It is fine now.
Where is she taking the cat?
Oh my god, we changed the- They changed the- Whoa!
He's going wild!
Stop her, someone stop her!
Someone stop her!
I don't know why the one I don't have the menu open, Min has
the words user and very poor above her head.
Min is too tiny to get the camera, you see that?
She's trying to get the camera.
camera she's too tiny all right good night all right all
right i admit you're heading off now too yeah all right i
want to say good night goodbye to miss good night good night
goodbye
you don't even just take off your headset yes your computer
is right here yeah just come a little oh fuck that all right
schnuffy take advantage of her but goodbye schnuffy i hope
you had your and your chat also had a really good stream too
thank you for coming This was so awesome.
It's an insane passion project.
I can't wait to tune in tomorrow and see all the
information, all the strengths and everything.
I would love to make, like, a sloppy sister's world in the
future, too.
That would be so fun.
Yeah, I mean, this already is just such an homage to, like,
our bond that it's so cute.
Even that it's, like, yo, it's Doki Lahn, but it feels kind
of like home to me.
I mean, I can't have Doki Lahn.
Oh, my God.
Alex Dragoon was like, we're a chemical, we're a raccoon in
sync.
I'm just so quick with the swipe.
I'm sorry, I put my hand down.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, um, um, um, um, um, um.
Oh, am I showing something?
She got too excited.
Sorry, she got too excited when she took the camera, I
guess.
She got too, too excited.
But I, there won't be a dokey line without the sloppy
sisters, though.
oh you're so cute you're cute right now oh my god look look
at you okay i'll let you talk to your child and everything
i'll be back on my sorry but thank you for having me yeah
thank you for coming you don't understand you don't
understand the kind of effort this woman put into this girl
this was month she said it but like even we knew like not
the extent of this whole world but this for like months and
she was like you guys i kind of have like a big idea going
what do you think passion project passion project queen yeah
i was like you guys want 3d models i was like guys i have
this you guys want free free 3d models but hey follow me
into this world yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you get your free
3d models as long as you come to dokeland you know
I Colleen Burger on her....
Yeah.
Remember to wear your Doki Lon t-shirt, when you're on
stream.
Dude, we should do that.
We should get like for doki on t-shirts.
Wanna ask the Mandler for like Doki Lon t-shirts.
Yeah, yeah.
For our...
Did you know what when family is gonna do?
Oh yeah, I mean like we would wear our Doki Lon shirts and
we could like, hey guys, like after our next collab, our
next Sloppy sister collab, we are...
Doki Lon 2026.
Yeah, Doki Lon.
We went to Doki Lon.
Bro, I want to do that, actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, in our next collab.
I'll stop rambling.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you for coming.
You go ahead.
I'm sure you're tired too.
Yeah, we're both tired.
But you have fun stream.
I know you just, like, you had, like, you woke up just now.
Merry Christmas, chat.
You literally like...
Where's your gun?
Where'd it go?
It's on your other...
Oh, it's on your other hand.
Oh, wait, zoom in.
Merry Christmas.
Oh, wait.
Stop.
camera that was a phoenix right reference if you guys didn't
get it okay i'm gonna get the fuck out of here thank you
guys for having me sorry i'm taking up so much time no it's
okay
bye-bye oh there she goes there she goes i'm gonna set my
chair real quick all right oh is she is she still there is
she gone now oh my camera's so far from me give me a sec i
gotta bring my camera back give me a sec it's like all the
way here wow i'm tired guys but before let's go to the info
board dragon come on come here with me we got i'm i know i'm
walking weird but I'm now sitting down oh I'm sitting down
now it was fun all the adrenaline is gone now with the
sloppy sisters gone all the energy I kept in me gone oh yeah
the SCZ's you guys when when the world's public you can be
El Changoon or Igoon or Longoon or dragon you can be any
goons you want to be that's right i know i'm so tired
i'm so tired but i had a lot of fun i had a lot of fun today
with the sloppy sisters it truly was i think this was truly
is the sloppiest vr reveal i've ever done but i think he
agrees he's been through a lot of of these VR stuff.
He's a veteran in our VR projects.
The Dragoon is a veteran.
But I think it wouldn't be a sloppy Sister's collab if the
VR world isn't sloppy too.
If the stream isn't sloppy as well.
All right.
I need you to get a good angle on this thing right here.
Zoom in a little
we're getting there yeah okay we're almost there guys we're
give me a sec he's new well he's not new but he's he's he's
a new cameraman but welcome to Dokilan the dragons number
one vacation spot my team worked so hard creating this world
as a celebration of all the amazing memories we've not done
yet though and we'll update this world in the near future so
if you guys see all like the little houses all around us the
saloon is able to be entered but the others aren't yet so in
the future uh we will have uh we will have an update in the
world where all these places like the you know dps bank um
the arm stuff the jail all this stuff they will you will can
you can enter them in the future um like i said this
project's been going around for half a year now they i don't
remember what month we started like july june i don't even
fucking remember it's been so long um this has been the most
hands-free i've been for a vr project because like i said
this entire year has been so fucking busy for me so i would
give input but like every couple of months i'd give input i
would disappear and be like and then like i'd be like you
guys got this and And then I come back and be like, okay, I
want to do this, this, this, and I'll disappear again.
And then I invited my staff team over.
And I was like, okay, you guys, I delegate to you guys.
If they are trying to reach me, they reach you guys.
And then the last December, in December, I was like, I came
into this world.
And I was like, change this, this, this, this, add this, add
this, and then we're good to go.
Last three days, add this, add this, change this, fix this.
change this add this bam bam and then they managed to do all
of that so shout out to my to this team um for so so shout
out to the team for managing to do all of that like making
like my vision in there um i like wrote some of the dialogue
lines because like some of the lines there i felt like you
know i want to make it more dokey bird more dragon community
i did change a lot of the dialogue lines around here to have
more of an homage to like all the stuff that you guys like
about my streams or like memories you built over there and
what else the logo that logo was made in two days because at
first it was I was like I don't like the logo we gotta fix
that and this logo was made in two days shout out to Orca
that's why I was like emergency I need a logo maker like
right now and then we got this logo in two days and like
dropped that in um but anyway i just realized we didn't
finish reading this but um maybe you'll even make new dragon
friends by visiting this world i cannot thank all you enough
for always supporting me throughout the years and helping me
create all these wonderful projects i hope we continue to
make more memories together in 2026 because like i said this
world was very expensive um this has to be my most project
I've ever funded um and um I could have done that without
you guys supporting me watching the stream donating super
chatting being a member um subscribing it really does help
out a lot we are able to create amazing things like this and
more amazing things in the future and I hope I can create
more amazing things in 2026 um with you guys and with the
team that we have um and like I said send some hearts to you
guys um and like i said um i think it's gonna be really cool
we're gonna have like i said just like the good old days we
did it one time in the past some of you guys might remember
this a long time ago um where we did like an official meet
and greet uh with a lot of our fans here um in a vr in the
previous vr chat world i did um for you guys um and we're
bringing it back we're bringing back i don't know how many
times we're ever we're going to be doing this but um the
sloppy sisters are going to have our official meeting greets
in this world in doke land and um and we're going to select
time that won't be fucked for limo because i'm not i'm sorry
guys if you're in asia you guys might have to wake up really
early i'm sorry either really early or like really late for
the asia goons out there because um we gotta make sure that
if It's all our time zones, especially for Lamo.
And she's British.
I know it's Cree.
Some people are like, she's British?
Like, she's British, by the way.
I know.
You can't really tell, too.
But for those who don't know about this, we did this one
time.
Mia Mint did this one time, a long time ago.
It was also my idea.
And it was really hard to get perms for it.
but now we don't need perms so we could do it whenever we
want how many times we want uh just matter of our schedules
line up but um the sloppy sisters and i we will be we will
be doing official meeting in dokylan so basically it's just
you guys make a bunch of instances or join up with other
dragons or whiffs sorry i booze um and like live oh my gosh
i'm sorry i'm so tired i don't remember what live moose fans
are called or or snuffy's fans are called i but um um and
you know uh we will be hopping world to world basically
that's how it's gonna go that's how we've done it before and
we're just gonna randomly hop world to world to world and me
as many Many fans as possible.
Chat with all of you guys as much as we can.
Are the chattos and the...
Or is the chattos and the snuffbirds.
Or, okay, you guys must be...
Snuffufu.
The snuffufu and the lambupus.
Lambupus and the snuffus.
Sorry, the labupus, the snuffus, and the lambupus.
And the dragons.
will meet as a dragukus dragukus we will meet as many as
possible can and like I said we want if you have been able
to like you know not like you know the past but like you
know if you did have a chance to do one of these when the
sloppy sister you're doing then other fans have a chance to
meet us as well but for this instance we're not talking
about like the past past I meant like you know if you got a
meet in Doki Lan and then you jumped into another world and
saw us again um let us have other fans have a chance to talk
to us as well especially those from East Coast I'm always
hearing like people whenever events get asked people like
West Coast gets everything like guys let the East Coast
goons have a chance to yeah we'll do an honor system but let
the East Coast goons have a chance greets as well as the
asia goons and the eu sorry eu goons as well
east coast goons can't have nothing what do you mean i feel
worse for the eu goons and the asia goons what the you guys
talking about what about the bro they're fucking starving
right now oh yeah and lat america i'm sorry and and And
then, and South America.
Let the South American goons get something, too.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
There's so many things I want to show.
Okay, wait.
Come here, cameraman.
Let's show them something that we weren't able to show.
This was something I wanted to show you guys.
Look at that.
There's so many fun things.
so you guys recognize this place down there you guys
recognize this place cameraman show them this place wait
actually use yeah yeah yeah you guys recognize this
yeah it's literally next to us it's literally the game it's
literally the game what this place was from my bounty hunter
debut my first my fucking crazy ass debut we recreated it
it's actually gonna be a game that you can play not now
though because this guy got tired I'm joking I'm joking but
he did a lot he did a lot it's also the camera the other
goon like didn't even get to see you anymore he they changed
the camera angle so they can't see you cry oh yeah okay that
doesn't get this guy this guy got tired so um it's we'll
have this finished soon we'll have it finished soon um but
you'll be able to play in here and it'll be just like it'll
be like the game it'll be just like battle birds oh my god
we should have named this battle birds bro we should we
should we should have named this battle birds i just
remember okay we might have to change the title we might
have to change the title it's okay so um so currently
currently it's called okay we'll keep dokey versus it's like
it's called dokey we'll keep it as dokey versus um we'll put
what do we put battle birds at the bottom them and like it's
like in crayon okay well i have an idea it's like in paper
we'll have like a tape or some shit like a like a paper tape
and then in crayon be like battle birds underneath like a
subtitle but it was like a sign underneath like we forgot
about and we're like oh shit battle birds we that was a
little thing we might have forgot but there's games around
is all over here um Oh, oh, I want to show this.
Also, we have a beggar here.
He wants to look at him.
Are you going to let him die?
Wait, cameraman, look at the dialogue.
Look at this poor dragon, guys.
Look, spare some super chats for a homeless goon.
You're going to let him die like that?
Why am I naked?
What do you mean why am I naked?
are normally naked the shark wounds took my clothes that
poor guy should pay your fucking debts all right there is
something I wanted to show though in the saloon come with me
look here do you guys recognize these
wow it's the dokey jam games so there you might wreck
there's a bunch of dokey jam games that are scattered across
the map as well right here yeah we have them as cartilages
and then there's something i want what was it i'm so tired
bro i'm over here i'm i'm so tired
final stretch the final stretch everyone we got this i'm
having fun though i'm having fun dragoons what a great way
to start the year what an amazing way to start oh here this
one this is why i want to show you guys come here cameraman
show this look at this this is a little a little book the
project team made a little message from everyone you can see
all the people that have contributed special message to all
the dragons who visit so read this later read this when
you're in this world and read their messages it's really
nice it's very sweet it's a very sweet message um what else
what else oh yeah oh my god we didn't get the wait where's
his face cameraman up here you know the wall mount show the
wall mount up there
the wall mount the wall no not that no were you not looking
at what I was pointing at okay yeah I mean there's that but
where's his other half look see look at that I killed him
that's right that dragon over there did not pay his debts so
don't fuck with me you Show them the other half too.
I don't I don't waste parts That's his ass
That's right So remember to pay your debts All right, let's
go out
Come here come Oh wait look who's also here
there he is
yeah we're gonna keep his little secret
don't worry I won't tell all right anyway so all the
wonderful people who worked on this project guys i'm gonna
push stream an hour later guys i'm so tired i just tomorrow
i need to push in an hour later i'm like i'm like running on
through fumes right now but i really want to show you guys
this because this is very important so guys i'm trying to
turn on the button i'm sorry please don't judge me oh there
oh my god i pressed okay here you go here we go here you
Here are all...
There's me.
That's me over there.
Right there.
Do you see me?
That's...
That's me over there.
Right there.
That's me.
I'm Doki Bird.
Right here.
Happy New Year.
And then we have...
We have the project leader.
The drawers.
We have Jin.
The conceptual artist.
Will.
Outlet.
The graphic designers.
Wuka, Naki, Orca, the code guy.
That's him.
That's that goon.
Wait.
That's him.
That's the goon.
He's the cameraman.
He's this guy right here.
The code guy.
The guy that danced for us.
All right, now back to the camera to you.
He danced for us while we were trying to find Min.
that's the dance cat and um 3d mascot who did all the
dragons and the the costume designs for the dragons this is
a uh oh wait katasumi who designed our 3d models me all the
sloppy sisters people who create who created who created the
3d models uh based off of katsumi style uh rika you and then
the the 3d people all the wonderful 3d people that worked
very hard um legends res salted and oh shit sorry squid i
clicked on and squid
thank you thank you to everyone that worked so hard um these
are all the fan arts too if you your fan art in the game
these are other people's fan arts that we included in our
world so we hope you know you find your fan art in here and
then you can change the change the music if you want like
right now we can change all the music in here and everything
so yeah all right dragon follow me
but um i'm so hungry guys i didn't eat dinner all right
camera here camera here all right no actually no no not
camera here that's not a good pov all right follow me i'm
trying to find aesthetics guys i'm trying to be
aesthetically pleasing all right here oh it looks weird
because I'm not actually sitting on a chair.
It's okay.
It's...
This works.
Oh, I could pretend to sit on this chair.
You're right.
You're so right.
Here.
Wait, can I actually sit on it?
Oh, I can.
Oh, there we go.
All right.
Oh, but I won't be on the...
Okay.
Wait.
Do I have a fireworks?
Am I next to...
Do you see the fireworks here?
Camera moon.
Which way do I look?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, okay.
I wrote something that I want to read out.
Oh.
Let me see if I can find it.
I really want to read.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I'm okay.
Wait, what's going on with my arm?
Guys, wait, which arm is this?
Wait, which arm is this?
What happened to my arm?
Oh, my God.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Apparently I can't move closer.
So...
I got an idea.
Let me pull it up.
Okay.
I'm gonna pull it up.
I want to read this before we go.
I wrote something very special.
I wrote something very special for you guys before we go.
But, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I got it.
Guys, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I got this.
I'm sorry, I'm all over the place, but don't worry, I got
it.
I'm sorry about all of this.
I'm so tired.
Thank you.
I'm a mess right now.
I'm a mess.
I need you guys to know.
I forgot to get contacts.
Literally today.
I'm a professional.
The longer it goes...
stress eating um but I actually forgot contacts as well so
you know I remember the story of how like accessing through
my last pair of contacts I had to call like literally I was
like today I was calling all the glasses I did something
illegal today someone also did something illegal today but
basically like um you're supposed to get contacts
prescription and I don't have contacts prescription cut the
tape cut them oh my god Jack was like, I'm not liable for
this.
I did not know she did something illegal today.
But basically, you're supposed to get contact prescription
to get contacts, but I didn't get contacts prescription, and
all the eye doctors were fully booked.
I called, like, three places, and I just got her a mic, and
I was panicking because I was like, holy fuck, I can't wear
glasses like doing VR because it's not great.
it's terrible so basically um I was like I because I was in
the middle of a trial run for contact so and I never like
got it officially and I called the third place and I told
them because like the first and second place we're like we
can't we can't sell you contacts we can't give you trial
ones because you need to you need to get your prescription I
was like can I book a prescription right now they're like
nope you can't we're fully booked and I was like I need it
today and we're like we can't do anything sorry because we
can't give you a trial run because you don't have a contact
prescription and in a third one I called you she's like y
'all can give you some and I'm like oh thank God I came over
and I was like how do I pay and she's like technically um I
didn't give you any contacts she was so nice I'm gonna buy
glasses from her in the future she was like um technically
we did not give you anything
yeah yeah she gave me a two months of trial run contacts she
literally gave me like, like, yeah, yeah, what contacts,
wink, wink, oh, I can't wink up right now.
That's, yeah, yeah, she saved my ass.
I'm definitely going back for actual classes.
This conversation technically never happened, um, because
she was like so nice.
She was like, yeah, I can give you, I can get you something.
And then I was like, oh, I was like, what time do you close?
And she's like, oh, we closed at five.
And I was like, oh, I can, like, she's like, I can like open
like I can I Can have the store open for longer.
I was like no, no, it's okay.
I'm heading over right now like she literally was gonna open
like have the store open for later If I wasn't gonna make it
by five it was actually fucking crazy But yes technically I
technically I did not get contacts today She didn't give me
nothing Yeah, it was so sweet.
It was very sweet.
I literally told her like this I've needed today like this
is an emergency like can I is it okay?
could you have like an eye doctor can't get a contacts
prescription like right like today like she's like oh i no
you don't need it i can give you a try i can give you some
contacts right now and i'm like oh what okay anyway sorry
sorry time sorry time is over sorry sorry i had to tell you
guys this but uh okay i don't know if this works okay there
you go all right i really want to tell you guys um i don't
know how i look right now i hope i look okay i don't okay do
i look okay right now like because i have to tab out to read
this that wrote for that wrote for the new year okay i look
okay that is good to know that is good to know all right if
i don't look okay wait dragon camera goon send me i can see
like the emojis flying in camera goon if i look okay send me
a check mark emo green emoji if i don't look okay send me a
red emoji okay all right happy new year dragons there's a
lot of things i want to do in 2026 and i want to focus more
on being creative again i couldn't have done any of this
without your combined support either from super chatting
joining my membership or even just watching and sharing my
clips all you have helped built this and helped enable me to
keep on doing what i love i hope you dragons new and old
will continue to be with me and the community for years to
come and accomplish many more things together let's get to a
million subscribers and to creating many more wonderful
memories yay happy new year happy new year thank you
everyone thank you everyone for all the akasupas for all the
super chats for all the memberships for the subscriptions
thank you all for joining thank you all for watching thank
you all for being here uh thank you to the staff team for
working so hard um for the project team as well to our
fellow goon our fellow two camera goons is the other camera
goons still here oh yeah get her over here she doesn't need
to do the p of like when we end we'll do the camera angles
of everything right everything when we end i'll tell you
when to do it let's get the other the other goon here let's
get the other goon here i feel like vacation at Doki Lan
yeah is she here get her over here like I feel like I feel
like you know like oh oh she's coming in she's coming in
there she is all right all right wait give me the camera my
turn it's my turn with the camera that's right stand over
there with her Alright, so the big Chonky Goon over there.
Guys, okay, personal space, guys.
So, the Chonky Goon over there, her.
She's actually the project leader.
So, give a huge shout out to Chonky Goon, Jules, for being
the project leader of the entire thing.
And then Entity, to the right, the Long Goon, was the coder
for everything in this world and also the camera.
They were both the cameramen today, too.
and women so huge whoo huge round of applause to their hard
work for staying up and doing everything here for us today
and all their hard work I want you guys to know that we
actually had like an emergency or sorry an emergency with
our camera an hour before the stream was supposed to start
we were testing out the camera system and we me and longoon
were fucking panicking and freaking out because we had a
little little bug for the camera system but we made it work
i was like i was like it's okay we won't be in the world we
won't be in the world until like two hours so you have an
extra hour to figure out what the fuck is going on and i
literally said to him quote unquote if this doesn't work i
will be
I was like, um, if I, if this cat, if there's this bug, I
would be angry.
No pressure, by the way.
But it was like jokingly.
I like laughed after.
I was like,
right, right, Dragoon?
It was a joke, right?
Yeah, see?
He's nodding.
He's nodding, no, no, no, no.
Keep nodding.
what was the bug so you don't see it anymore but basically
in VR chat you get to see this there's a camera monitor that
we can I can see where I would know what's going on so when
but and it was showing up on the camera and that wasn't good
because it was very like unimmersive because wherever I go
my camera will suddenly randomly show up like not camera but
like my monitor so I know like what at and everything and um
and then so like we had to figure out what the fuck to do to
fix it so they literally was are you okay oh my god she
tripped and fell
anyway so um so we they managed to fix it like um because i
was like okay don't worry like we're gonna stall until this
is fixed um that's why um we were like walking or like this
we view this world like right away it was you know always at
the end um but they fixed it while we were obviously trying
to find mint too trying to find mint someone call the
ambulance but yeah anyway shout out to the team yay i will
not stand up i am too fucking tired just yay we did it we
did it everyone we did it it's over yippee i'm gonna make my
you to make my waiting room for tomorrow because i'm going
to pass out actually i'm going to get food and then pass out
yeah but thank you everyone thank you for coming i don't
know the world will be public we have a lot of things we
want oh um we have do have some things we need to fix for
the public release there were some things we're going to fix
for the public release and also add right guys right we have
a list of stuff we're going to add and fix for the public
release and then um and then it'll be released i don't know
yet maybe it'll release in tomorrow maybe release later this
week who knows we'll figure this out later but then you can
visit dokeelon too the happiest place on earth yeah are you
guys happy you guys are happy right dragon are you happy
yeah the happiest place on earth dokeelon let's go better
than disneyland yeah all right chonkegoon um segue us out
with the camera angles show out them i'll start i'll put it
back on show everyone the lovely camera angles.
I'll show those gestures.
I'm going to turn off the fireworks too.
There we go.
Yeah, do a little tour of everything.
Just a little tiny tour.
Yeah!
Next angle.
Whoa!
It's so much cheaper.
is free guys you can come into this world you don't need VR
to come into this world by the way by the way this this
world in VR chat it's free and you can play on PC to explore
everything as well so it's not like limited to VR yeah you
can talk to all the NPCs as well I didn't talk to every one
of them so make sure if You guys want to explore yourself?
Talk to all the NPCs and have fun.
Yeah.
There's the cemetery.
Yeah, there is desktop mode too.
Yeah, these are the games we weren't able to show you guys
because we were running out of time.
But I hope you guys, I'll talk more about it tomorrow as
well.
Explore the world in desktop mode tomorrow.
I'm not going to explore the world in VR.
I think I'm too tired to be in VR.
whoa but yeah thank you all for coming wait actually yeah go
explore all the camera angles and then we will end come over
here everyone give me my i wish i'll stand under here like
my my idol mr mickey mouse
oh all right camera camera one come over here
all right show this make sure yeah good i don't know what
happened to my other camera wait give me a sec let me see i
can get my actual camera
there you go now i can see what you guys are looking at to
Dokiland the happiest place on earth we hope you come back
again but in seriously in seriousness thank you all for the
support guys 2025 was a hell of a year I'm so I'm so tired
now you know why December is was my hell month December
everything happened in December I everything was in December
I oh my god that's why it was so hard to reach me I'm so
sorry to my project team it was so hard to reach me it was
everything happened in December um um but happy new year
what a great way to start 2026 we ended with the sloppy
sisters and we started with the sloppy sisters this year um
what I'm I'm really happy to be able to welcome in the new
year with them.
It was so fun.
Like I said, the models were a Christmas gift.
They were like, please, are you sure?
Are you sure?
Like, do you not want me to pay?
I was like, no, no, no.
This is a Christmas gift.
You guys, you guys made me really happy.
And they made me really happy.
And, you know, we created, had so much fun together.
And they're really great friends of mine.
And I hope they enjoyed the models.
And I'm glad they enjoyed Dokilon, you know, because, you
know, this was like my world like at first it was just gonna
be me and I asked them they wanted to join me for the
countdown and they're like yeah of course yeah sure like of
course um so I'm really thankful to the sloppy sisters for
giving their time and joining me because like I said I'm
like the last one I'm like the last one for 20.5 like they
all had their individual new year celebration and then they
hop after they celebrated new year they hopped into my
stream to celebrate my new year um so huge shout out uh um
to the sloppy sisters And he shouted to the project team
again for the hard work and creating all of this.
Like I said, this is the most expensive VR world I've ever
funded.
It was crazy.
At one point, I will tell you guys this.
Usually I'd be like, no budget.
At one point, my manager had to step in and was like, we
have to put a budget.
That was how bad it was.
He was like, we have to stop this.
He came in and was like, guys, guys, we have to put a
budget,
because they're like wait we because the part two was like
wait i thought it was nobody like guys guys we we the mad my
manager's like guys
so uh yeah um but yeah and but yes thank you for joining me
and welcoming 2026 everyone stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around wow to get that blood flowing maybe
stayed up for me because it's very late right now head to
bed cuz you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye where's the camera angle cuz bye guys come on
get to get to camera angles Come to the overview.
Bye, guys.
Cameraman, come to the overview.
Bye, no, no, you do not shake your...
Okay, there you go.
Okay, okay, bye, everyone.
Bye, everyone.
Wait, why are they seeing me right now?
Wait.
Oh, my God.
camera goon camera goon the camera was it the camera was why
did you not say anything I couldn't see I oh my god I didn't
see okay I gotta give me a sec I did all that oh my god Oh
my god.
Guys, guys, come on.
Oh my god.
Where did my thing go?
I can't believe it.
Oh, now.
Wait, now?
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, now you guys.
When was it like this?
Guys, when was it like this?
When we went here.
When?
Why didn't you?
I can't see it.
I can only see what the camera sees.
Oh, my God.
I can't see yours.
Okay.
Okay, we'll do this.
Okay, take two.
It's like we're filming a real commercial for Dokilan.
It's like, it's like, okay, okay, quiet.
It's like we're, it's like, okay, action, right?
okay all right all right all right when was it like this
first stop not not you i'm last chat when was it like
oh my god when i retrieved my camera i've been talking for
so long.
I don't even remember what I talked.
Okay, we're just gonna do the outro all right, take two.
We're just gonna do the outro that's why.
All right.
We had such good camera angles and everything right?
The camera angles were so good.
It was so good.
It was such a good speech too.
He had such good camera angles as well, I would say.
Stay hydrated.
I even did this.
Okay, you guys, I did this posture check.
Bro, I fucking stretched my back for this.
Oh, we're not to do this yet.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Oh, my God.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye, bye, bye, okay, God, okay, happy new year, happy 2026,
everyone, yeah!